the Scarlet King is a really bad guy
he's a giant interdimensional nightmare
God intent on breaching our reality and
Wrecking terrible havoc on everything we
know and love he's been responsible for
Untold suffering and Chaos across
countless worlds timelines and layers of
reality to many he's even somewhat of a
final boss to the SCP Foundation and
just when you think he couldn't get any
worse it turns out that he's also a
deadbeat dad not only did the Scarlet
King once have a cult literally named
the children of the Scarlet King before
it was destroyed by Dr Monto in the SCP
Foundation he also had at least seven
actual children each one is speculated
to be a powerful anomaly but it's tough
to find concrete answers as to who or
what exactly most of them are so today
we're putting on our researcher hats and
digging deep into the foundations lore
to present our theories on the potential
progyny of the SCP foundation's greatest
enemy and if nothing else we may finally
be able to get this dark lord of all
evil to start paying all the child
support he probably owes by now first if
you're not well versed in Scarlet King
Vore you may be wondering how exactly
does an evil chaos God have kids is
there a Scarlet Queen out there who
prefers to stay out of the Limelight the
answer isn't quite that simple and it
has everything to do with SCP 231 and
Big Red's most devoted cult the
non-biological Children of the Scarlet
King they kidnapped a group of seven
girls and performed a number of dark
rituals that resulted in them becoming
vessels for the Scarlet King seven
terrible kids these seven girls have
become known as SCP 231 anyone who
accesses those files and trust us they
aren't a pretty sight we'll find that
the containment procedures mostly
involve performing the infamous Monto
procedure on the surviving girls to keep
them from giving birth six of the Seven
Brides have given birth to nightmares
Beyond Comprehension and are now dead
with only one still remaining
successfully contained but here at the
SCP Foundation you need to learn to
comprehend the
incomprehensible according to a
classified document SCP 231 May
technically be a neutralized anomaly
without us even knowing and incidentally
this gives us our most certain answer on
the children of the Scarlet King on this
one the Apple fell very very far from
the tree according to the secret
document SCP 9999 that's right the
adorable Tickle Monster is the seventh
child of the Scarlet King he must be so
disappointed that everyone's favorite
little blob didn't want to join the
family business of absolute evil for
anyone who doesn't know SCP 999 is a
slimy yellow entity that only seems
capable of absolute compassion it brings
joy to everyone in its presence and with
prolonged exposure it can even cure
disorders like PTSD anxiety and
depression
he's so good at this that he even cured
SCP
2317 his de facto mother of her trauma
and allowed her to return happily to her
family after some amnestic treatment the
Scarlet King has another good reason to
be ashamed of his cheerful Blobby son
ancient DVID prophecy dictates that SCP
999 May someday become so powerful that
his force of absolute love and good
overwhelms the Scarlet King's evil and
Chaos think of him as the Luke Skywalker
to the Scarlet King's Darth Vader though
we probably can't expect a cool
lightsaber battle between them anytime
soon how disappointing so if SCP 999 is
the quiet sensitive black sheep of the
Scarlet family who's The Golden Child
who makes his evil father proud the real
chip off the old block that would be our
dear reptilian friend SCP 682 the
malicious lizard heavily implied to be a
child of the Scarlet King if you know
literally anything about 682 your
reaction to find a find ing out that
he's the spawn of Cruelty personified is
probably yeah that makes sense just as
SCP 999 is the Scarlet King's innocent
optimistic young child 682 is kind of
like his edgy teenager still in the
middle of a misanthropic face he shows
no sign of leaving anytime soon the fact
that 682 appears to find anything about
the world around him utterly disgusting
seems to be a trade he inherited from
his dear old dad and the fact he seems
pretty much impossible to kill also
lends Credence to the popular Theory
he's got nightmare God blood running
through his veins 682 has also started
displaying a particular hatred for 999
ever since an incident where 999 tickled
him into submission so family dinners
are probably extra awkward for these two
999 and 682 are the most certain
children but that still leaves us with
five more children to identify it's
worth remembering that the waters are
murkier from here on in but we've
searched far and wide through the
foundation archives to find possible
answers if your interpretation differs
remember that it's just a theory an SCP
explained Theory thankfully we do have
some assistance here the tale dust and
blood hinted at what each of the seven
children of the Scarlet King represents
and that may help us narrow down our
choices here to put things into
perspective it's believed that 682 was
the fourth child to be born representing
wrath and 999 was the seventh
representing hope according to this Tale
the first of the seven children
represents dominion and as a result is
skilled in the ways of war and has the
power to lead the king's forces to
Victory according to One Foundation
theorist this child could potentially be
SCP 239 also known as the witch child
this entity is so powerful that as part
of its normal containment procedures
it's eternally kept in a coma why
because this seemingly normal child has
dominion over real reality and can
change it to her whims her thoughts are
so powerful that just her brain waves
can damage physical matter and she can
make things disappear or manifest in an
instant she's also impossible to kill
with skin that's almost totally
impenetrable much like SCP 682 she's
also frighteningly strong in both the
offense and defense department we're
talking about such a powerful telepath
that Dr klef has campaigned for her
immediate termination just because it's
for that way this is certainly a
frightening wonderin that the Scarlet
king would be proud to call his daughter
next the second child according to the
prophecy this child represents longing
the child has the power to bring forth
armies which will help the Scarlet King
in his Conquest for this we actually
have a pretty unconventional Theory SCP
029 also known as the daughter of
Darkness if the name alone wasn't enough
to suggest that she's got an extremely
Sinister father she also fits the
profile of being very aggressive and
incredibly hard to kill but even more
damning is her connections to the
symbology of longing one of her most
dangerous Powers is causing men to fall
into almost trans-like Devotion to her
after spending time around her they're
suddenly willing to murder in her honor
strangling their victims in hopes of
raising khi the Hindu God of destruction
whom has many similarities to the
Scarlet King she certainly fits the bill
of someone capable of raising armies in
the dark lord name one strike against
our Scarlet King connection theory is
that the file States the daughter of
Darkness was first discovered in India
which wouldn't match up with the other
information we know to be fact however
while this is a long shot given the
sensitive nature of everything involving
the Scarlet King it's extremely possible
that false information was supplied to
bury the connection considering the
coverups and lies involving anomalies
like SCP 1000 this certainly isn't an
unprecedented move move on the part of
the foundation next the third child this
child is associated with all things
desolation implying destruction fire
ashes pestilence and death across the
battlefield when it comes to spreading
destruction and Death on a mass scale
one particular SCP comes to mind SCP
058 the Heart of Darkness this creature
has Scarlet King written all over it
it's evil it's mysterious it's pretty
much impossible to kill and it causes
Mass casualties every time it escapes
its containment chamber it causes fires
whips people to death with its razor
sharp tendrils and sprays highly
corrosive acid from its scorpion-like
tail and it's even red given that we
know for a fact this entity suddenly
emerged out of something that's now been
expunged from the records in an
undisclosed site it's extremely possible
that the entity 058 came from was SCP
this is a child that the Scarlet king
would definitely be proud of given that
it's impossible to reason with and feels
solely motivated by causing destruction
misery and Chaos we can't think of an
entity that better suits the Desolation
moniker than SCP 058 next skipping P SCP
682 at number four the fifth child of
the Scarlet King is associated with the
loose concept of lack the prophecy then
goes into more detail saying that this
child is powerful in the ways of magic
and is able to use their abilities to
cause great destruction here we have
another unconventional proposal what if
child number five wasn't actually a
child but children that's because we
think this description perfectly fits
SCP
1765 the nightmarish reality warping
sisters who we think may actually be
Triplets of the Scarlet King's fifth
bride now hear us out these are actually
some of the most powerful enemies that
the foundation has ever attempted to
contain and we know nothing about their
past before being bound to a few objects
by the Serpent's hand these sadistic
reality warpers are so devastatingly
powerful that the only action the
foundation can take against them is
letting them have free Reign Over the
containment site they currently inhabit
all the foundation can do is hope they
never get bored of tormenting the people
inside as we all know the Scarlet King
despises science progress and order so
perhaps a perfect punishment for the
foundation in his many eyes is giving
them a taste of their own medicine the
sisters though particularly their ring
leader are a perverse shadow of the
foundation's love of the scientific
method they take these methods and use
them for an activity that the Scarlet
King finds much more enjoyable
tormenting and killing people whenever
these crafty triplets set their mind to
it their horrifically powerful magic is
able to cause massive Devastation just
like the prophecy for the fifth bride's
Offspring dictates and finally the sixth
child of the Scarlet King the concept
associated with this one is hidden
meaning it can change its face and walk
unnoticed through creation it's also
said to have the responsibility of
opening the ways between worlds and
allowing the war to end all wars to
first begin there have been a huge
number of guesses for this spot with
some even suggesting SCP 055 the anti-em
but since we're having fun here we also
want to make an even Wilder suggestion
we posit that the sixth child of the
Scarlet King is Allison Shia also known
as LS and the black queen the most
powerful member of the Serpent's hand we
get it we have a lot of explaining to do
but hear us out Allison Shia is a member
of the Serpent's hand or technically
many members multiple versions of her
exist across parallel dimensions in the
SCP Multiverse they're mostly all EST
strange Daughters of foundation
researcher Dr Charles gears this
estrangement leads them to collaborate
in the wanderer's library the secret
base of the Serpent's hand to conduct
raids on the foundation in Revenge but
what if the leader of these alternate
Allison had an ulterior motive because
in the infinite number of possibilities
offered by the Multiverse this one was
not the daughter of Charles gears but
the Scarlet King she's merely using the
pain of her counterparts to manipulate
them into accomplishing her true
father's goal undermining the SCP
Foundation let's break it down the
hidden child is prophesized to walk
unnoticed through creation not only does
Alison Chow appear human the use of SCP
268 a news boy cap that causes the
wearer to become unnoticed allows her to
walk anywhere through creation without
being detected but most importantly of
all the hidden child is said to be the
one who opens the way for the Scarlet
King's entrance into our Dimension and
Allison Chow has access to to the
wanderer's library an unfettered access
point between Dimensions if one of the
infinite Allison was the secret daughter
of the Scarlet king would the wanderer's
library not be a perfect way for him to
leave his own Dimension and enter ours
she could be the final piece he needs
hidden under the nose of the foundation
and the Serpent's hand making all the
secret power plays to allow for the
Scarlet King's eventual bloody revenge
on our world unless of course SCP 99 the
family disappointment stops him first we
realize that some of these theories may
seem surprising but when it comes to the
anomalous especially the Scarlet King
the only thing you can ever expect is
the unexpected do you agree with our
theories if not who do you think are the
children of the Scarlet King let us know
down in the comments one thing is for
certain we hope we never meet any of the
terrible tyrants nasty children except
the Tickle Monster of course he can hang
with us any time warning this site is
for SCP personnel with 05 approval
access Beyond this point for those with
standard level four security is
prohibited and may result in termination
of foundation employment unauthorized
visitors who survived the AA kill agent
are detained and interrogated under
truth exacting the medic agents Dr
Herman Wright was used to high security
protocols he had been working with the
SCP Foundation for several years and had
dealt with specimens both terrifying and
valuable but something about this site
was different the security was tighter
than he'd ever seen and it all seemed a
bit too much for what looked like a
run-of-the-mill warehouse in Alexandria
Egypt the street seemed normal it was
surrounded by businesses selling food
and clothes and none of the locals
seemed to give a Second Glance but as
soon as he was approved for Access and
entered the warehouse it was a very
different story he looked into the
Cognito Hazard testing screen designed
to cause psychic damage to anyone who
hadn't been inoculated by the foundation
and entered the large bunker automated
guns lined the walls he could see the
outlines of trap doors below him and he
was pretty sure the whole place was
rigged to blow if a large scale assault
hit the foundation was taking no chance
with whatever they had found in Egypt
what could they be keeping locked up
below as Dr Wright walked through the
long tunnel leading to the staircase he
could see a series of rules marked on
the wall no open Flames allowed within
SCP 401 no firearms or bladed weapons
allowed within SCP 401 all riding
utensils brought into SCP 401 must be
approved by a majority of the 05 Council
violating these conditions could cause a
CK class restructuring scenario or an XK
Class end of the world scenario Dr W's
mind raised as he entered the massive
anti- chamber and descended the
staircase but he wasn't prepared for
what he saw it was a library the biggest
library liary he had ever seen with
bookcases stretched as far as the eye
could see the library was Far bigger
than the warehouse look from the outside
and Dr Wright assumed it must be a
disguise built on top of the much bigger
older facility that had been discovered
by the foundation it wouldn't be the
first time the foundation found
something that didn't conform to the
laws of ukian geometry SCP locations
often played by their own rules as Dr
Wright exited the staircase and walked
up to the first bookcase he could swear
he heard rustling sounds among the
shelves was something moving he hadn't
seen anyone walking the aisles when he
descended the staircase and he was
pretty sure he was alone here wasn't he
making things stranger a quick look at
the bookcase didn't show any books he
was familiar with none had standard
titles in fact they all seemed to follow
a simple format each title a different
individual person all books look the
exact same same binding same thickness
same number of pages was this some sort
of SCP reference library suddenly a hand
slapped down on Dr right shoulder and
his heart nearly jumped out of his chest
he turned to see a gray-haired man in an
SCP lab code extending a hand to him Dr
whan Henri Chief scientist in charge of
testing at SCP
401 you must be Dr Wright he didn't give
Dr Wright a chance to respond Dr henrix
didn't seem like the kind of man to be
very interested in what others had to
say yes yes about time the foundation
sent me a new research assistant I
suppose you have a lot of questions Dr
Wright was supposed to be a researcher
not an assistant he didn't suppose it
would do any good to point that out when
Dr Wright tried to question what it was
that he'd be researching Dr Henrik told
him that it would be easier to show than
explain with that he motioned Dr right
to a nearby table where one of the
countless identical books on the shelves
was waiting he nodded at the book book
prompting the younger doctor to turn it
over and read the title he couldn't
believe what he saw there on the front
of the book was his name Herman Wright
Dr Wright looked at his colleague in
confusion and Dr Henrik motion for him
to take a look it was written in a
language that he had never seen before
but was somehow instantly recognizable
and understandable and the book really
was about him every detail of his life
had been written down in this volume
starting with his birth containing
details that no one but he knew his
whole life story was here from his
childhood to his education to his
eventual recruitment by the SCP
Foundation but the book wasn't completed
the last line that had been written
described his entry into the secured
confines of SCP 401 that very day Dr
henrix had a mad glint in his eye are
you starting to understand one for each
of us every person who has ever lived
roughly 100 20 billion people since the
dawn of man their lives all written down
in these books every time someone is
born their book appears in this library
and their story gets written as it
happens the foundation has been
monitoring this site since the 1800s but
it's been operating much longer than
that since the dawn of recorded history
Dr henrik's past talk to write another
book it was simply titled the Hunter and
it chronicled the life of a prehistoric
man who spent his days searching for
Wild game he lived 23 violent monotonous
years before his story ended abruptly
when the saber-tooth tiger decided it
was interested in the same Mammoth he
was hunting this must have been one of
the oldest books in the library a book
for every person on Earth Dr W could
only imagine what the scale of this
massive Library must be Dr Henrik
explained that mapping the library was a
huge challenge before producing a map
from his pocket and laying it out on the
desk you at base camp this is where new
births generate on the shelves along
with books pertaining to the first
humans if you want to drag down specific
books you'll need to know where you're
going we've established base camps
around the library to Mark significant
errors in human history with notable
books at each Camp you'll find
generators supplies and beacons to light
your way if you're going back far enough
you could be traveling for days or even
weeks Dr Wright was fascinated by this
bizarre location containing the sum
total of Human Experience within its
massively expanding walls but there was
one thing he couldn't figure out just
why was this seemingly harmless location
featuring constantly changing books the
most securely guarded SCP he had ever
encountered Dr Henrik knew he was
referring to the extensive rules he had
must have seen as he entered the other
doctor reached into his pocket and said
let's just say that around here the pen
is mightier than the sword he pressed
the pen into Dr wri's hand and flipped
open the back page of his book it was
blank the rest of his story waiting to
be written what something you've always
wanted in your life dror right think
literally why not put it in your book or
remove something you've always wanted
gone slowly Dr W thought back to his
teenage years and recalled an injury
that he suffered in a mugging that
damaged his leg and left him with a limp
he nervously used the pen to scribble
out the words and sentences describing
the event after a few seconds he felt a
headache and suffered from a slight nose
bleed after that the limp and pain from
the injury was gone and he could no
longer recall the event you see Dr
Wright that's the secret of SCP
401 Dr Henrik said with a mad gleam in
his eye this Library doesn't just let us
read the history of humanity it lets us
write it that's why you're here to test
the limit of this power and see what
this Library can do for the foundation
Dr Henrik soon provided Dr Dr Wright
with footage of some of the many tests
conducted in the library and what Dr
Wright saw amazed him the books could
rewrite the laws of nature with alarming
speed as some unfortunate d-class
Personnel found out D
0546 was brought into a room with a full
head of hair the d-class Personnel was
instructed to scribble lost all hair
into his book and he soon started
scratching his head as he rapidly
started shedding hair after less than 2
minutes the man was completely Bal
d
0567 a young woman who had been brutally
injured when attacked by an escaping SCP
was bedridden and would never walk again
according to all the foundation doctors
as the d-class Personnel used a pen to
scribble Over The Line in her book
describing her injury Dr wght watch as
she suffered a minor nose bleed and then
sat up getting out of bed as if she had
never been injured and no longer
remembered being attacked Dr Clare
Williams a foundation researcher sick
with cancer wrote into the to the book
about curing her symptoms and then
addressed the camera explaining that
this was her third time altering her own
book her lymphoma symptoms had returned
after several months and 2 years
respectively but it seemed that as long
as she continued to make changes to her
book then she could keep the cancer at
Bay
indefinitely but not all the tests ended
with positive results as Dr Wright moved
on to another selection of tapes labeled
mortality tests a d-class Personnel who
was given a fatal dose of drugs and then
had their death erased from their book
45 minutes later miraculously returned
to life but showed significant cognitive
deficits after another d-class an older
woman killed in a Containment Breach had
her death erased from the book but came
back deeply Disturbed she survived 15
days in containment repeating send me
back let me go over and over again
before committing suicide a d-class
Personnel killed 28 days prior was
brought back by writing return back to
life in their book but died again just
13 minutes later from a cerebral
hemorrhage but it was the next tape that
was the most disturbing it documented a
new book that was written by the
foundation depicting the life of a
fictional man down to the slightest
detail it was carefully placed in the
correct position in the archives
resembling all the other books and Dr
Wright watched the tape in amazement as
the man resembling the fictional
character created for the books
spontaneously generated in SCP
401 almost IM immediately the man
started vomiting blood and died less
than 2 minutes later the book carefully
described all the things he died from
and stated that this was exactly as it
was supposed to be the fake book then
disappeared into the archives never to
be seen again the archive knew when it
was being used to play with life and
death and it didn't want any part of it
the next tape wasn't a test at all it
was a video interview showing a Greek
speaking scientist speaking with an
ancient looking old man found living in
the archives slowly after its Discovery
by the foundation the man who described
himself as The Watcher of Alexandria
Eternal believed he was keeping the
archives safe from the Roman Empire and
the other Invaders He was unaware that
thousands of years had passed since his
watch began he had been using the books
to write himself another day of life and
to cure his ills ever since he began
guarding the library at the conclusion
of the interview he asked to leave and
this request was granted by the
foundation the ancient man died of old
age shortly after setting foot out of
the library while the library can't
technically cure death it does seem to
have nearly Limitless ability to prolong
life as long as someone is willing to
stay close by and never forgets to write
themselves another day where did this
incredible power come from an 05
authorized investigation into the
origins of SCP 401 revealed that under
the archives carpet is a concrete floor
covered by a layer of Ash the ash was
carbon dated to between 70 and 880,000
years old in further analysis revealed
the ash is likely to be the remains of
burnt wood and paper despite their being
no known records within the archive
itself about a major fire having
occurred there Dr Wright didn't have
much time to dwell on the library's
great power of life because he was
suddenly shaken from his thoughts by the
sound of alarms was the library being
breached no it was Foundation officials
led by a man recognized as Dr Lincoln
Abrams the very man who was signed him
to this project and he did not look
happy he explained that he knew what Dr
Wayan Henri had been up to writing in
books changing the lives of subordinates
in an attempt to play God he knew about
everything of course because he had read
Dr henrik's own book he knew all of the
doctor's Secrets he knew everything no
I'm so close Dr Abrams I know I can
crack the archives rules there's a way
to conquer death here I can feel it Dr
Abrams was done listening and with with
a wave of his hand Foundation security
took Dr Henrik into custody for a
debriefing and likely to motion Dr
Abrams then turned his attention to the
new Young researcher Dr Wright eventful
first day I gather I'll appoint a new
lead scientist shortly but until then
don't disrupt anything remember the
archive is writing our stories as we
speak it's not very happy with Dr
henrik's make sure your story turns out
better and with that Dr Dr Abrams and
his security team departed leaving Dr
Herman Wright alone with the endless
archives of Alexandria Eternal wondering
what would be written in his own tone as
the sound of new books popping into
existence filled the air with ominous
rustling the year is
1941 and the world is gripped by the
most violent and widespread war in
history Millions marched to War as
bloody battles are fought across the
globe horrendous atrocities are carried
out on groups of people and parts of
London are bombed to Rubble on a weekly
basis considering it's only been 20
years since the last World War it must
seem to the early residents of the early
20th century that the world is coming
apart at the seams and amongst the chaos
it'd be easy not to notice a secluded
Manor House in the English Countryside
disappearing Without a Trace for 11 days
before suddenly returning to our reality
but thankfully one organization makes it
its sole duty to notice unnoticeable and
understand the impossible the SCP
Foundation and within that anomalous
manor house foundation agents and
researchers were about to find Horrors
Beyond even their darkest
imaginations this is the grm tale of SCP
1461 better known as The House of the
worm when the manor house reappeared
after its 11-day absence the foundation
zeroed in sending agents inside to
invest investigate it was a two-l
dwelling complete with 12 bedrooms four
baths three studies a main foyer SL
Ballroom a library a kitchen and a
pantry basement the foundation observed
that a number of these rooms had been
fitted with rows of bunk beds similar to
a boarding house or Barracks only later
would they understand why they found
that the upper portion of the home
exhibited no abnormal qualities
whatsoever but as the agents
investigated further they found an
entrance to the truly anomalous portion
of the manor the extensive suev system
no previous records of the building kept
by the local Council indicated that
there would be anything below the
Manor's basement so either the
mysterious previous occupants who were
nowhere to be found had built this suev
or it just appeared here on its own
regardless of which was the case agents
and researchers knew that whatever had
happened down here had everything to do
with the Manor's mysterious
disappearance they descended ended into
the depths of what seemed like a
man-made Cave System constructed
primarily from a mix of concrete iron
and Brass it was a behemoth of 20th
century technology intricate snaking
systems of pipes gears and pumping
Pistons it was like someone had built an
entire Factory down here but for what
the agents began to spread out through
the Labyrinthian vows of the manor
hoping to find some answers but all they
seemed to discover was more questions
this Place hadn't been built with any
form of comprehensible logic it was full
of dead ends stairways that ascended and
descended to Nowhere doors that would
open to reveal just walls behind them or
not open at all it was like a maze built
by a maniac it didn't help that it
looked like the place was recently hit
by an earthquake with some passages
caved in and mangled Machinery strewn
about it seemed that no human workers
had interfered with the impossibly
complex and bizarre Machinery in quite
some time a number of of the materials
used to construct said Machinery as well
as the gray Sandstone filling in the
collapsed passageways remain
unidentified to this day already the
suble was proving to be a complex puzzle
box with only an estimated 75% of its
layout ultimately being mapped by
Foundation researchers however they
would soon realize that this place
wasn't just confusing it was deadly the
only method of self-maintenance detected
by the exploring agents were pipes that
would fire a thick black lubricant onto
the surround ing Machinery one of the
foundation agents had The Misfortune of
getting covered in it while exploring a
darkened passageway and 80% of his body
was melted as a result it appeared that
the viscous black goo was incredibly
corrosive to all organic matter a number
of the machines also emitted dangerously
High quantities of gamma and x-ray
radiation making it difficult to explore
many of the caverns without heavy Hazmat
protection and worst of all were the
extremely hostile creatures living in
the caves who had would regularly attack
Foundation Personnel these Abominations
came to be known as SCP
14611 vicious SteamPunk Frankenstein
monsters once human but with large parts
of their bodies replaced by crude
mechanical implants including metal
teeth and Claws 1461 d1s have displayed
a taste for human flesh and they have
dragged multiple Foundation agents down
into their layer to be converted into
monsters like them it's believed that
cp1 1461 is capable of controlling these
bees through the Strategic use of sound
from its brass speaking pipes leading
them into areas where Foundation
Personnel are present to instigate
conflict many of these pitiful creatures
have had their throats replaced by
photographs endlessly repeating the same
nonsense phrases over and over again I
am what you have made me I am choice and
I am tyrany forgive me I am then and I
am now what gods they will be then I am
even evil and I am flesh I am the Trap I
am Beauty and I am chaos children are
selfish I am the worm I have broken God
still in spite of The Mazes monsters and
deadly chemicals the agents persisted
and managed to discover several
important locations the gel production
chamber on subl 3 creates glass jars
from the unidentified sandstone and
fills them with a slime that looks to
contain living eyes and teeth the
factory delivered room is filled with a
huge number of crates and boxes which
seem to shift and change in number
between Foundation patrols the speaking
tube room on sublevel 11 contains a
grand Pulpit that acts as the Connecting
Point for the complex array of speaking
tubes running through the entire Cave
System the body parts of a deceased
female also appeared to be wired into
the Machinery like spare parts and on
sublevel 12 they found the so-called
Catalyst room here they discovered a a
huge complicated Clockwork and steam
powered machine that appeared to be
broken and missing some parts most
horrifying of all though is the raised
platform in the center of the Catalyst
room on top of which is a metal hospital
bed a desicated male corpse rests upon
the bed its chest punctured by large
syringes connected by tubes to some kind
of pumping machine the parts connecting
this pumping machine to the overall
apparatus of the room were missing
though leaving its purpose a mystery the
foundation assumed that fluids used to
be drawn out of this corpse to somehow
power the machine you may be starting to
worry that there doesn't seem to be any
answers here that this house is one big
mystery but lucky for you you're wrong
an old Journal was also discovered in
the Catalyst room and if what was
written inside is to be believed then we
may finally have some truth about who
created The House of the worm why it was
created and what horrible events
triggered its mysterious disappearance
and reappearance his true name has been
redacted by the foundation and special
efforts have been made to maintain
secrecy around the house seeing as it's
an anomaly of great interest to a cult
known as the Church of the broken God so
we'll just call the one who made this
place the inventor before any of this
the inventor was one of the many
Englishmen traumatized and almost killed
in the horrific trench battles of World
War I after a near-death experience the
inventor like many gen Geniuses and
madmen was plagued by surreal and
nightmarish Visions he saw a huge
creature that he referred to as the worm
a gigantic metal monstrosity with
dragon-like Jaws full of nashing Gears
that Rampage through Europe destroying
and devouring everything in its path
these apocalyptic Visions also presented
him with a solution vague blueprints for
a machine that might be the salvation of
him and others willing to take his new
gospel to Har and Escape from a world
that the inventor knew in his heart was
about to end he hired work starve
laborers from across the country to help
him make his visions of reality and
began a massive secret construction
project beneath his isolated country
manor house for the inventor it was all
a labor of love he wanted to protect his
wife son and daughter from the terrible
jaws of the Worm but as the project
stretched on his wife began to suspect
that he'd lost his mind many of his
workers however felt just the opposite
they became infatuated by the inventor's
sermons on the nature of the worm and
the coming apocalypse they hoped to
escape soon enough they had become a
Bonafide cult constructing the elaborate
sublevels underneath the house in
preparation for the fast approaching Day
of Reckoning then came World War II the
inventor saw Hitler hungry for War as
one of the avatars of the worm finally
knowing that the time was right he
activated the machine and successfully
trapped the worm in the bowels of his
mechanized home however as the blitz
raged and London's bombing began the
inventor felt as though he hadn't
stopped anything he realized once and
for all that he was never meant to stop
the apocalypse only Escape it and by
throwing the final switch and setting
the machine he and his followers had
built into overdrive he did just that
this was the moment that the house of
the worm disappeared transporting the
inventor his family and his devoted
staff to a different world an empty gray
World devoid of War but also lacking all
the Comforts of regular life including
food things went downhill from there as
their supplies quickly began to run out
and the cult descended into cannibalism
in order to survive things weren't going
much better in the inventor's personal
life his wife fearing what would happen
to the family took her own life and the
life of his daughter though by this
point the inventor's mind was so
fractured that it's possible he may have
killed them himself either way it was
only the inventor and his son left and
more trouble was brewing udora one of
the staff trapped in the building with
the inventor and his cult started a
mutiny she claimed the worm spoke to her
from below and that their only path to
Salvation was pleasing the worm how
would they please it a sacrifice of
course they would give it the son of the
man who had trapped it the mutineers
took the inventor's only remaining child
and descended into the lowest Su levels
the inventor followed hoping to track
them down save his son and Salvage
something from this nightmare as he
ventured deeper battling the members of
eudora's new cult he found that they
were changing themselves becoming the
half-human cyborg creatures that the
foundation would later discover the
inventor would find udora herself in the
speaking tube room her body still living
was wired into the machinery and she had
sacrificed his son to the worm in a rage
the inventor murdered udora or whatever
was left of her then heard a familiar
voice speaking out of a nearby speaking
tube it said I am what you have made me
I am then and I am now I am choice and I
am tyranny I am evil and I am flesh I am
Beauty and I am chaos I am the worm the
voice was his own in that terrible
moment the inventor realized that the
worm wasn't a giant all devouring
monster
it was him in trying to protect his
loved one from a perceived apocalypse he
brought them all to their horrible
demise he' trapped them with the monster
he'd H for them all to escape from
because no matter what you build you can
escape from who you are grief stricken
and broken the inventor descended into
the Catalyst room there was his son
stuck with the syringes drained of all
life to fuel the Mighty Machine his
father had created in his his last
moments the inventor decided to do the
only Noble thing he threw himself into
the machine destroying both it and
himself in the process the house was
transported back to our own reality but
the worm in a sense was no more but who
knows if the worm is really dead its
thoughts and poisonous intent still
lingers in the caverns and rattles
through the speaking pipes whatever
really happened the foundation is still
picking up the pieces to day and who
knows what lurks in the parts still
hidden from our knowledge London is the
second largest city in Europe and
underneath this bustling city is one of
the oldest and largest networks of train
tunnels in the world but that's not the
only huge old structure located beneath
the city of London below even the
deepest underground Metro stations of
this historic City there's a whole
artificial world of surveillance cyborgs
impossible architecture and stomach
churn earning nutritional supplements so
be sure to mind the gap because we're
about to take you on a tour of SCP
1678 also known as un London SCP 1678 is
located 1 km below the city of London
England from all appearances it seems to
be an exact copy of the city though
aesthetically it's more in line with how
it was around the turn of the 20th
century gas street lights stand on every
corner and the modern skyscrape ERS of
the business district are recreated in
the style of Victorian architecture the
epicenter of construction appears to be
the houses of Parliament which is
evidenced by the more unfinished and
flawed the city becomes further out from
the center one goes some of the
buildings are made of nonsensical
materials like copper pipes and some of
the gas lamps are nothing more than a
ball of disembodied light floating a top
of metal pole the first big question
that the foundation had upon discovering
this location was of course
why on Earth was it created and they
wouldn't have to look far as an
explanation of this bizarre mirror City
plays automatically upon entering my
fellow citizen if you are hearing this
tape then the world as we know it is
finished the sky has broken the ground
heaves with the of terrible feet
and all the horror and Madness from the
dark corners of the world has broken
free to exact its Vengeance on the world
of man evil has raised raised its bloody
flag upon all nations of the world and
crowed its Unholy Victory to the broken
Sky yes this is the end but there is a
New Hope welcome to un London a city of
survivors a city of the free together
fellow citizen we will wait and prepare
for the new beginning the grand new
world that is soon to come let the world
above burn we will endure let the
monsters have their world we will
prepare we will wait and I tell you
citizen that there will be a new morning
and you will emerge from un London and
stand blinking in the Sun and on that
day citizen there shall be a new order
as we raise the Union flag over the
entire world I welcome you to one London
the last City and the first from this
message it seems that this mirror city
was built to be a refuge for survivors
of an apocalyptic scenario but the SCP
Foundation had no knowledge of such a
plan in fact it's still unknown who
created this place or how they did it
the one fact that was evident to the
foundation was that even though this
strange place was intended to be a safe
haven it was far too poorly constructed
to actually act as one illumination was
unreliable and most of the buildings
were damp and infested with mold it's
also unclear to the foundation where the
oxygen and gas supply of un London was
coming from throughout the day the
loudspeakers around un London play
automated messages such as no one is
safe from the influence of mimic beings
Bryson's home for the PO is here to help
and crime will not be tolerated in un
London the tormentors of society will
become its Defenders at the end of every
hour that passes the speakers announce
the time followed by and all is well
when the SCP Foundation first entered on
London it was unknown whether or not any
living things in inhabited the city on
first investigation it seemed from its
state of disrepair that the city had
been long abandoned but soon the
foundation met their first inhabitant of
the underground city mobile task force
members were inspecting the area around
the houses of Parliament when they
discovered what looked to be a bank as
they approached the doors they heard the
following announcement over the nearby
loudspeakers citizen you are entering a
restricted area have your authorization
papers ready ababi will arrive to ask
scort you shortly this signaled the
approach of SCP 1678 daa also known as
the bobbi's a single instance of SCP
1678 a appeared with the unmistakable
sound of a police whistle and as soon as
it arrived it started attacking the
members of the task force another
announcement came over the speakers
police halt criminal the bobies are the
main threat to visitors in un lundon and
they will attack on site with any
improvised weapon they can find true to
their name they are all dressed in
uniforms consistent with those of London
city police officers from the Victorian
era what sets them apart from their
historical counterparts is their
construction these beings are made out
of human corpses crudely dismembered at
the joints and reassembled using metal
hinges and bolts with their heads
wrapped in bandages Bobbies are
extremely hard to kill with only High
caliber rounds and explosive weapons
being effective at putting them down
autopsies of dead bobies have shown that
underneath the police uniform the bobies
all wear Prison inmate style jumpsuits
this adds a chilling context to the
announcement about the tormentors of
society becoming its Defenders it
appears that the bobies are the
reanimated bodies of prisoners in
addition to the bobies the foundation
cataloged two additional forms of
artificial life present within on London
first are SCP 1678 DP or eyes in the sky
hybrid biomechanic IAL birds made of
Flesh with an exoskeleton of copper
wiring some of these creatures are
covered in a deteriorating outer layer
of plastic and Feathers suggesting that
they were originally meant to resemble
pigeons as their name suggests eyes in
the sky serve as a type of surveillance
drone and while they have no offensive
capabilities they still pose a
significant threat to the foundation
it's still unclear whether they're able
to communicate with or summon the
Bobbies but the SCP Foundation takes no
chances
the last life form present in SCP 1678
is the strangest and the most
frightening SCP 1678 DC known as the
wretch the wretch has only ever been
encountered outside the Zone which is
now under SCP Foundation control and
it's uncertain how many instances of
this being exist the wretch resembles an
old woman or sometimes old man dressed
in filthy rags the wretch sits at street
corners holding a begging tray and will
attempt to elic at pity from anyone who
happens to walk by the wretch will ask
for food or money but if food is
supplied it will start weeping before
Vanishing into a puff of black smoke on
a few occasions audio notices playing on
the city's loudspeakers have alluded to
this being saying do not pity the wret
allow them to pay the price of their
betrayal for all eternity the current
Foundation protocol with regards to the
wretch is to not engage with it at all
in addition to the bobbi's the eyes in
the sky sky and the wretches there's
another strange component to the world
of un London throughout the city in any
area designed for human habitation the
foundation discovered multiple machines
that resembled modern gas pumps these
machines are fitted with coin slots and
rubber hoses that when coins are
inserted dispense a porridge-like
substance advertised as Dr Goody's
Wonder food according to posters around
the city wonder food is a meal
replacement supplement supposedly
containing all of the required nutrients
for survival Wonder food also appears to
be the only food source available in un
London despite the claims by various
posters around the city that Wonder food
contains all the nutrients you need and
completely restores health and vitality
examination of this substance has
revealed that it is much like the rest
of un London unsuitable for sustaining
life tests have confirmed that Wonder
food is a synthetic starch gel heavily
enrich with various minerals vitamins
fats and bulking agents and it contains
contains artificially engineered DNA
Helix structures while it does contain
all the elements required for short-term
survival consuming the product for
longer than 6 weeks will result in
severe malnutrition and eventually
scurvy further tests have shown that
wonderfood also contains psychoactive
properties the porridge contains a
mixture of unknown molecular compounds
which through regular consumption make
subjects calmer less anxious and less
likely to resist Authority it also seems
to have been engineered to cause withraw
small symptoms that set in if a person
stops eating it symptoms which include
headaches and depression Foundation
Personnel are forbidden to consume
Wonder food but the substance is highly
attractive to instances of SCP 1678 B
and 1678 C like most things in on London
the quality of Wonder food varies wildly
with some dispensers putting out a
product that is so degraded that it can
cause sickness deformities or even death
in the consumer but strangely the
foundation has also recorded a type of
unknown colorful mollusk which feeds on
spillage from the wonderfood dispensers
at present un London is only partially
contained mobile task forces to 4 and
Epsilon 6 have succeeded in establishing
a perimeter around the Hy Park District
where they have managed to stop any
incursion from SCP 1678 a even though
this is the only area that is fully
under Foundation control Explorations
have been conducted of buildings outside
that perimeter the investigations are
vital for the foundation's main purpose
in un London which is figuring out who
built it and exactly what kind of event
this underground mirror city was meant
to prepare for the interior of the
Natural History Museum yielded
particularly strange insights into the
purpose of on London for the most part
the museum is close to how it appears in
the above ground but with one key
difference the task force investigating
the museum discovered an exhibit called
the fall of Man exactly where the Darwin
Wing should have been the exhibit as it
name suggests details the apocalyptic
scenario that would have theoretically
driven people underground into un lundon
but to everyone's surprise its diaramas
and displays didn't depict an asteroid
impact plague or nuclear Armageddon to
the foundation task force members the
scenes of Destruction depicted in the
exhibit were far more familiar they
recognized The Reptilian form of SCP 682
the ordinary looking Brownstone basement
door that serves as a gateway to SCP 23
17 and most chillingly the imposing
many-eyed figure of the Scarlet King
these were only some of the known ker
class scps depicted in the museum
exhibit it was clear that even though
the SCP Foundation hadn't built this
city whoever did knew a lot about the
SCP foundation's activities it's
believed by the foundation that whoever
or whatever created on London still
resides in the houses of Parliament and
the ultimate goal of the task forces is
to infiltrate the building but in order
to do do that they will first need to
find where the bobies are made and halt
their production it's believed that
Bryson's home for the poor is where they
originate from but it's unclear exactly
where the materials to make them come
from nor is it clear just how they're
produced ultimately the foundation's
goal is to catalog the entire city and
once they have stopped the production of
more bobies MTF to 4 and Epsilon 6 will
storm the houses of Parliament and
contain whatever Force has created on
London but London is a very big city and
un London is just as big so there's no
telling what else they might find
exploring this bizarre
location it's a perfect day for a
wedding on a warm spring afternoon a
bride and a handsome groom are
exchanging the special Rings they had
custom designed and made for each other
as they take turns placing the rings on
each other's fingers a man standing at
the end of the wedding party steps out
of position he approaches the groom's
next to him and reaches into his jacket
taking out a pair of pliers that he
hands to the groomsman the groomsman
happily takes the tool and then without
any hesitation shoves the pliers into
his mouth and begins removing his teeth
one by one when he is finished he hands
the bloody teeth to the man along with
the pliers the man then goes to the next
groomsman who repeats the same process
he continues going down the line until
all of the groomsmen and bridesmaids
have removed their teeth seemingly with
without pain or resistance the man then
approaches the bride and groom he hands
each of them half of the pile of teeth
which they gladly accept they then begin
to eat the teeth without delay seemingly
not bothered by the intense damage
they're causing to their own teeth and
Jaws by doing so the man watches as the
groom moves the priest who was
officiating the wedding aside as the
entire church looks on in Joy the groom
opens his mouth and the deafening sound
of cicas are heard heard this is only
the beginning of what the SCP Foundation
has labeled an SCP 2852 event a
terrifying and little understood
phenomenon that is better known by the
nickname of the anomalous creature
responsible for them cousin Johnny the
foundation had been trying to contain
cousin Johnny for decades not that it
ever done them any good Johnny is a ker
class anomaly that's thus far proven
impossible to contain this is an entity
so dangerous and volatile that three
different mobile task forces are devoted
to detecting and disrupting its
activities MTF Upsilon 36 aka the party
crashers MTF Upsilon 52 AKA cater Duty
and MTF Upsilon 99 aka the alter boys
but so far all the foundation has been
able to really do is Swoop in afterwards
and do their best to pick up the pieces
of people's shattered lives cousin
Johnny has so far been observed to only
operate in the North American
subcontinent and only seems to appear at
Anglican or Catholic baptisms weddings
and funerals however foundation
operatives charg with keeping a lid on
cousin Johnny Harbor the hidden fear
that he may one day expand his hunting
grounds and wreck Terror worldwide if
Johnny became multinational or
multi-denominational his violence
insanity and pure evil May truly become
impossible to minimize so compatible
communities are constantly monitored for
increased levels of juvenile delinquency
St
domestic violence and divorce after all
this you're probably wondering who or
what actually is cousin Johnny and how
does he cause so much horrific tragedy
at face value nothing about the
appearance of cousin Johnny would
suggest an anomalous nature or even any
sort of danger he appears to be a
middle-age white male often with scruffy
hair and a beard on a cellular level two
cousin Johnny appears all too human but
when you look at his physiology it's a
whole different story cousin Johnny has
no identifiable organs whatsoever his
body is made out of a fibrous muscular
tissue the only exceptions are his teeth
and hair which are made out of a kind of
kiten a key component of insect
exoskeletons such as those possessed by
cicas Johnny's eyes are the first clue
that something is off about him from a
distance they appear perfectly normal
but up close they're glassy and dead
this is because his eyes aren't actually
attached to any nerves inside his head
with no nervous system or vocal cords
Johnny's ability to see move and talk
defy any kind of logical explanation his
speech will seem completely normal to
the people under his spell but to anyone
else it comes out as complete nonsense
often described as word salad if people
in attendance are briefed in advance
about this phenomenon whatever hypnotic
ability causes them to hear his sounds
as intelligible words won't work and
they'll be aware of how nonsensical it
all sounds but of course that doesn't
mean they're safe cousin Johnny appears
at family gatherings and religious
rituals and immediately he'll be treated
as though he's always been there you
know your cousin Johnny right you go way
back or at least you're pretty sure you
do nothing will appear unnatural about
his sudden presence in fact if you're
one of the victims of one of his
incidents chances are you'll actually
find yourself taking a shine to cousin
Johnny sure his sense of humor is a
little crude and runchy but you can't
help but enjoy his company he's a fun
guy to be around and after all he's
family as previously mentioned he'll
only appear at three different kinds of
events baptisms weddings and funerals
and only those that are affiliated with
either the Catholic or Anglican
religions the SCP Foundation has
classified baptisms that cousin Johnny
attends as blue level events weddings
are known as white level events and
funerals are Black Level events with
each one escalating in severity violence
and horror first baptisms the blue level
events in these events cousin Johnny
will appear and begin to act as a third
god parent despite their traditionally
only being two as the infant is lowered
into the holy water the entirety of
their top layer of skin will come off
like a molting snake despite looking
horrific this apparently causes no harm
to the child the god parents will then
eat this discarded skin as though it's
the most normal thing in the world after
this the family will leave the church
together and cousin Johnny will leave
with them he won't appear at any
subsequent celebrations of the child's
baptism of course this is just the
beginning of the terror following cousin
Johnny's appearance at the baptism the
child's risk of dying in the next 6
months skyrockets and if they survive
they're at an increased risk of becoming
unstable and violent later on in life
their parents and godparents will both
become unable to conceive any further
children and are likely to be found dead
from drowning within 5 years of the
event those who are only tangental inv
involved in the baptism ritual have a
massively increased chance of failed
pregnancies or if they do conceive they
may become a danger to their offspring
children who live through blue level
events and survive past adolescence will
experience adverse side effects when
encountering the songs of cicas well
into adulthood from experiencing
physical sickness to going through
dangerous psychotic episodes weddings or
white level events are more complex and
severe in this case cousin Johnny will
insert himself into the as a groomsman
and the most horrifying events will
begin to take place after the vows have
been exchanged Johnny will provide
various implements that allow the
Bridesmaids and groomsmen to remove
their teeth which are then given to the
bride and groom to eat which they do
causing severe damage to their own teeth
in the process the groom will then
vocalize an unknown cicada call at an
incredible volume as loud as 140 DB in
some instances rendering the bride and
everyone else near the altar completely
deaf at the wedding reception where
everyone is continuing to behave as if
nothing out of the ordinary is happening
cousin Johnny will ruin things farther
by giving the best man speech the speech
is more of his typical complete nonsense
though if you're there you'll never
realize this and think that this is the
best speech you've ever heard with some
in the audience laughing hysterically
While others cry uncontrollably once his
speech is done he'll present a gift to
the newly married couple 3.5 kg of human
hair in various colors 13 deceased
specimens of a certain cicada known as
Lin cicada and 23 human teeth in a
cardboard box DNA tests on all the gifts
have been inconclusive as to their
origin much like many celebrity
marriages unions that occurred during
white level events Never Last and all
end up divorced within 2 years often as
a result of domestic violence and any
children born during their brief
marriage will be violent and unstable
but it's not just the wedding party that
gets to experience the fun of a visit
from cousin Johnny all married
individuals who attended the wedding
will find that they are unable to
conceive children despite no biological
indicators of infertility any children
present at the white level event will
show no interest in Romance throughout
their life and often die tragically
before reaching the age of 18 finally
and most horrifying of all are funerals
or black level events while blue and
white level events can potentially be
disrupted before they are completed
lessening or preventing the horrific
results there is as yet no way to stop
or prevent a black level event at any
stage any attempts to prevent cousin
Johnny from entering the church or
Funeral Home will lead him to Simply
manifesting inside once in the room
where the funeral is taking place cousin
Johnny will first take up the role of
eulogizer and begin speaking his
standard nonsense to the attendants the
person who was emotionally closest to
The Departed will then open the casket
if this was not already an open casket
funeral and will then produce a large
number knife it's unknown where the
knives come from as they're not present
before the event and they disappear
after the funeral attendees will then
use the knife on their wrists and
sometimes throats draining their blood
into the coffin many lose more than
enough blood to result in death but none
ever die from this nor do they seem to
feel any pain from their wounds as the
attendees take turns bleeding into the
coffin cousin Johnny continues his
eulogy which eventually evolves into a
cicada song the kind sung by L cicada
males the attendant sing the same song
back to him in a kind of call and
response cousin Johnny will then
approach the coffin and vomit in a
mixture of blood wood pulp and dead
cicas the funeral will then proceed as
normal and the blood vomit and cicada
filed casket is then taken to the
cemetery and buried Black Level events
will usually end with the body being
interred in the ground but if there's a
wake after the funeral the horrors of
the Black Level event will continue at
the a wake cousin Johnny will climb on
top of a table lie down and encourage
the other attendants to devour him which
they do all the while he continues to
talk his nonsense until there is nothing
left much like blue and white level
events being an attendance leads to
horrific After Effects all participants
who experience this event will separate
from their family through either suicide
moving or divorce every individual
present at the event will also find that
they are no longer able to produce
Offspring and couple's presence may also
fall victim to incidences of domestic
violence often involving cannibalism
that usually leave one or both
participants dead while six out of 10
children involved will attempt to murder
one or both of their parents before they
turn 18 these black level events are so
horrible for all involved that any
members of the specialized cousin Johnny
mobile task forces that happen to
witness such an event are treated with
class A amnestics before they are
transferred to another task force or
retire to ensure that they don't have to
live with the memories of what they saw
prior to that they are closely monitored
for any strange or antisocial Behavior
to make sure they weren't affected by
the event and they aren't the only SCP
Foundation staff at risk of having been
impacted by cousin Johnny it is
theorized that as many as a third of
Catholic and Anglican d-class Personnel
were involved in the Black Level event
at some point and were driven to Madness
and violence by their fateful brushes is
with the strange relative that no one
knows so next time you're at a baptism
or a wedding or a funeral stay vigilant
keep an eye on the other guests and
always ask yourself do you really have a
cousin Johnny the SCP Foundation employs
hundreds of different procedures in the
containment of the many many anomalies
held in their walls from hermetically
sealed steel boxes to ordinary
observation rooms it is extremely common
for the entities in in containment to
attempt an escape and the foundation has
measures in place to protect against
these breaches and the Damage that they
can cause however there was one SCP in
containment that presented an abnormally
constant Hazard it wasn't the entity in
captivity though that created the danger
no it was the constant threat from two
additional creatures that were intent on
getting to the captured entity and
removing it from the foundation's grasp
and they were willing to destroy
anything that got in their way this is
the rather unique problem with SCP
1913 which refers not to a single entity
but to three one in containment and two
that would stop at nothing to get to it
this is the story of SCP 1913 the
strange team made up of Agatha Telly and
Freddy better known as the furies SCP
1913 consists of three separate entities
referred to as scp1
1913-1914 D2 and scp1
19133 after the initial discovery of SCP
1913 and its containment at an SCP
Foundation site the site was attacked by
SCP
193-211
19133 it seemed to be an attempted
jailbreak of sorts with two and three
determined to free one from captivity at
all costs after this initial attack the
three entities were classified together
as SCP 1913 and their behaviors and
Fates were undoubtedly intertwined
whenever scp1
1913-1914 containment procedures Convoy
Omega 8 also known as the Cats in the
Cradle was formed this team run by a
team of scientists that included the
young and woful inexperienced Dr Hayward
was tasked with handling the containment
research and movement of scp1
1913-1914 D1 is a ceramic statue of a
cat 20.5 cm in height it has the name
Agatha written on the bottom resulting
in the entity often being referred to by
that name it is painted white on the
nose ears and forehead and has a black
ink-like pigment around its eyes mouth
and Paws it has displayed sentients and
is capable of speech when Agatha talks
it has the voice of a young woman though
the statue's mouth does not move when it
speaks Agatha is not friendly toward the
foundation staff but will answer
questions when its container is shaken
though Agatha cannot move on its own it
should be treated with Extreme Caution
and only touch when absolutely necessary
this is due to the nature of the ink on
its eyes mouth and Paws if it comes into
contact with the skin of a living thing
the ink will soak into its por Force the
area touched by the ink will begin to
dissolve and disappear until the entire
body has been dissolved horrifyingly the
effected individual does not die until
their entire body has dissolved even if
they have lost vital organs arms and
legs left after the head and torso have
dissolved will continue to move on their
own moving around and grabbing at
objects the effects of the ink can be
stopped if it is washed off on the skin
before any disillusion can take place
though this will often still leaves
scars scp1 1913-d is a humanoid skeleton
covered with dark hair and Ash that has
the shape of a human female but with a
canine looking skull fingers and toes it
is unnaturally fast capable of reaching
speeds up to 65 kmph despite lacking any
visible muscle tissue unlike scp1
to act on orders given by the other two
entities and attacks anyone wearing a
lab coat or the standard armor worn by
members of the Cats in the Cradle it
will attack if provoked and will use its
claws to rake at the victim no matter
how much damage it does scp1 19113 D2 is
incapable of killing its victims and
they continue to live and suffer until
killed by another external Force scp1
1913-d has previously referred to this
entity as Telly and that nickname now
appears in official Foundation
documentation as well the final member
of this bizarre Trio is SCP
light Freddy is intelligent and capable
of communication though refuses to
explain its pursuit of Agatha when asked
about the subject its only response is
that this is a family matter when Freddy
attacks something it produces a burst of
gray Flames from its face holes these
Flames have been measured reaching
temperatures up to 1200° C these Flames
burn non-living objects in a relatively
normal way but when the fire comes in
contact with a living thing the flames
continue to burn until the subject's
skin has been entirely burnt away or
until the flame has been deliberately
extinguished Freddy has caused severe
burns to Foundation Personnel often
resulting in loss of sight hearing and
touch through unknown means though
likely because of a psychic connection
of some kind Freddy is able to know the
location of Telly and Agatha at any
given time now that you know the members
of SCP 1913 and exactly what they are
capable of it is time to get into the
events of encounter
029 most of what we know about the event
comes from the testimony of agent
Crowley who was present for the ordeal
he related the events to Dr Toki an
interview 1913 D providing a glimpse
into what exactly happened according to
agent Crowley it was a mistake for Dr
Hayward to be appointed to a position in
the Cats in the Cradle he was too new to
the work too green and something was
bound to go wrong Crowley insists that
Hayward should have been a to a safer
group first in order to build experience
and that what happened to him was not
his fault the Cats in the Cradle were
transporting Agatha to a new location
when they realized they were running low
on food and fuel they made a stop at
site 45- in order to refresh their
stores it wasn't supposed to take very
long only a few minutes after all they
had made Supply runs many times before
and had it down to a science at this
point it had been days since they had
seen Freddy or Telly however and the
staff was feeling very jumpy it was too
quiet and after a few days of peace they
had a terrible feeling that something
big was coming as Hayward and Crowley
drove into site 45's garage a fireball
suddenly erupted behind them a car had
exploded when the dust cleared there was
Freddy and Telly The Faceless dog and
the skeleton Cowley alerted sight 45
calling the security team and ordering
them to evacuate the facility of all
Personnel immediately Crowley grabbed
Hayward and attempted to make it to the
roof where they could evacuate with the
rest of the Personnel but before they
could make it there they were
intercepted by scp's
1913-s and 3 the two men ran into a
laboratory and locked the doors behind
them as Freddy and Telly attempted to
follow Telly began to scratch at the
door with its claws but when that didn't
work Freddy ordered Telly to step out of
the way using its Flames Freddy blew the
door off its hinges triggering the
building sprinkler system through the
Steam and smoke Freddy casually walked
into the room it didn't attack nor did
it order Telly to attack it simply made
its way over to Crowley and sat in front
of him Crowley asked why it was here why
it was doing this Freddy simply
responded that it was doing this as a
service and that its flame was
redemption in a moment of panic Dr
Hayward threw a microscope at Freddy
this foolish move only provoked The
Entity and it threw Hayward into the
counter with a burst of flame
though Hayward was burned the water from
the sprinkler system prevented him from
burning as badly as he could have been
but then Freddy ordered Telly to kill
Hayward for his impudence Telly picked
up Hayward and threw him into the far
wall of the laboratory where he crashed
into a Shelf full of jars the jars broke
open covering Hayward with their
contents rocks of sulfur tell he
prepared to charge at Hayward but
suddenly it stopped Telly and Freddy
both stopped their attack on Hayward
regarding the rocks that covered him
with suspicion even fear cley quickly
put two and two together and realized
that for some reason these two creatures
had an intense aversion to sulfur
Gathering more sulfur from the broken
jars he began pelting the two with
pieces of the rotten smelling mineral
Crowley was able to successfully Drive
Freddy and Telly out of the laboratory
and into an area where they could be
finally contained once and for all
Crowley then rushed Hayward to the
infirmary where the third degree burns a
cauterized hole in his chest would need
to be immediately treated though Gravely
injured he would eventually recover from
his physical wounds his psychological
wounds were a different story though as
agent Crowley said I live to see those
things tear out hayward's heart and so
did he currently all three entities that
make up SCP 1913 are in containment at
SCP Foundation facilities each entity
must be contained at least 1,600 km away
from the others each creature is placed
in the middle of a glass ring with a
radius of 4 M and the inside of each
glass ring is filled with sulfur dust
this prevents the entities from reaching
each other and has so far seemed to
prevent Freddy from psychically
determining the location of the other
two anyone handling scp1
1913-14 Agatha must wear latex gloves
and avoid any kind of skin contact at
all times if skin contact is made for
any reason the affected individual must
immediately wash their hands to remove
the ink from their skin if the ink
cannot be removed the infected staff
member must be terminated any staff
entering the room of scp1 1913-d must
remove their lab coats and armor in
order to avoid provoking it scp1
1933-35 prooof cell no one is permitted
to enter its containment facility it is
not known for sure what will happen if
the three aspects of SCP 1913 are ever
allowed to reunite some some have
posited that it will result in the
creation of a fourth entity some believe
that Agatha will change shape or
transform somehow some believe that
something entirely different
unpredictable and deadly will happen
putting all human life at risk we can
only hope that we never have to find out
for sure a pickaxe shatters the rocky
wall of a Min shaft hundreds of feet
below the Earth it's 1871 in a place
that will later be known as Columbia
County Pennsylania
men performing backbreaking labor their
hands and faces blackened with dirt all
working in pursuit of that immensely
valuable Rock Coal it's the fuel for the
booming Industrial Revolution and much
like how dragons were said to guard gold
this more modern treasure pointed to an
even more terrifying monster a monster
that the SCP Foundation would someday
come to know as SCP
1179 but these unfortunate and under
paid miners had no idea what they were
about to discover one of the men working
there that day Rob OD DWI was hammering
away at the wall in front of him when he
heard something strange was that an echo
behind the Rocks this could mean only
one thing the rocks in front of them
were Hollow there had to be some kind of
space hiding behind them owire struck
again and again at the Rocks in front of
him until the barrier finally tumbled
away he and the other miners suddenly
felt a gust of cool ancient air from
from the vast and darkened Cavern in
front of them sweep through the mind
they felt like they were standing on the
edge of something truly otherworldly as
they lifted their safety lamps high and
crept carefully into the dark it dawned
on them that they were likely the first
human beings to ever set foot here but
that didn't mean something nonhuman
hadn't gotten there first odo's lamp
soon found something in the dark a huge
figure curled into a crouching position
hiding its face it was made from Stone
like an enormous yet incredibly detailed
statue of something Almost Human but not
quite the Petrified thing had two great
horns on either side of its head
twisting into spirals like that of a
huge RAM word of the giant Frozen
Monster hidden in the bottom of the mine
soon made its way back to the foreman
and then back to the mine's owner one
sha Ali if it were anyone else perhaps
this news would have been taken to the
Press immediately and the foundation
would have taken control of the situ
situation just as quickly but Mr om Ali
was no ordinary mining magnet he was a
member of the Molly magui an Irish
American secret society whose members
were predominantly coal miners in
Pennsylvania Shawn and the other Molly
magu dubbed this anomaly the sleeping
Stone Giant and conspired to keep it a
secret between them as secret societies
have a habit of doing though the Molly
magui were disbanded less than a decade
later they were all sworn to secrecy on
the Giants rest place until of course a
descendant of sha Ali his grandson Ian
Ali was chosen as a prospective agent of
the SCP Foundation the foundation
doesn't just let anyone join their ranks
they perform an extensive background
check on all prospective agents both to
find out that they're capable of rising
to the challenges of the job and also to
detect any affiliation to enemy groups
of Interest it was during this
background check that omali Subterranean
Family secret was discovered and the
land above the old Min shaft was bought
up by a front company owned by the
foundation the sleeping Stone Giant was
finally incapable hands and in keeping
with standard procedure a research site
was built above the giant to gather data
and keep an eye on things at the time
the anomal was considered extremely low
risk its containment file read SCP 1179
is apparently dormant encased in the
Bedrock under research site apart from
simple monitoring in standard research
safety protocols no additional
containment is deemed necessary at this
time but of course those simple
containment procedures would soon need
updating in 1962 the town of Centralia
Pennsylvania had a trash problem there
were eight illegal trash dumping sites
across the town and to combat this issue
the Town Council opened up a huge
landfill in an abandoned Min shaft you'd
think this would be enough for the
moderately sized town but humans have a
tendency to produce a lot of trash and
they soon filled up the new landfill too
in order to address the issue the town
decided to do a controlled burn of some
of the garbage it should have been
simple enough but those who lit this
garbage fire didn't follow proper safety
procedures and ended up accidentally
igniting a seam of anthracite coal this
was like lighting the fuse to the
world's largest stick of dynamite and
fire soon coursed through the long
abandoned mine tunnels when the fireball
finally reached the sleeping Stone Giant
in its dark pit the Beast woke up in
that instant an otherwise uneventful day
quickly became a brutal blood bath
researchers walking through the Bas felt
a monstrous rumbling beneath them heat
sensors were burning up and seismic
readings were off the scale something
was climbing up towards them suddenly an
impossibly large sword speared its way
out of the floor killing everyone around
it with an immense blast of heat the
newly awakened monster went on an
underground Rampage almost completely
destroying the research BAS and killing
nearly everyone inside before retreating
into the honeycomb of coal mines and
caverns in the area igniting even more
anthros site coal fires the foundation
needed to step in before things really
got out of control at present the
foundation couldn't properly administer
standard area construction protocols for
ker class scps so they instead
designated the mines caverns and
surrounding Countryside as area 179 and
dispatched mobile task forces to try and
contain the Beast rampaging in the
Centralia mines but much like the fire
that started this whole mess the Beast
proved much harder to control than
initially imagined all five of the
expeditionary teams sent to apprehend
the monster failed and many team members
were slaughtered in the process from the
terrifying accounts of the survivors we
have a vague idea of the nature of the
Beast below no pictures of the creature
exist and exact descriptions on the
Beast can vary whether this is because
the Beast frequently shape shifts or
because it has some kind of cognito
hazardous effects on those who view it
is unclear the most frequently reported
characteristics of the creature are its
immense height and the extreme heat that
its body exudes many report that the
creature's body seemed to be formed of a
mix of hardened lava pure fire and
burning smoke the Beast measures over 30
m from head to toe with shoulders over 8
m wide it's commonly said to have two
huge ram-like horns and a weathered
bearded face the Beast has been compared
compared by some to the Norse
mythological figure cder the giant
guarding the frontier of the Norse fire
realm of moose Bal however the actual
age of the creature seems to predate
these Legends by a considerable margin
dating of the stratum Inc casing as CP
1179 indicates it dates to the
Mississippian sub period of the
Carboniferous period approximately
359.06
million years ago this age is consistent
with the geological age of this region
so it may have literally come with the
territory less common descriptions of
the Beast claim that it has huge Wings
eyes made of Hellfire and fangs as long
as a man's arm some say that the Beast
has neither horns nor fangs and its face
is encircled By Flames which reach down
into a long beard of fire and like a
certain creature known as the ballog
that Lord of the Rings fans will be very
familiar with this Beast comes with
weapons in one hand the Beast wields a
giant burning sword around 5 m in length
in the other it wields a huge multi-
tailed Whip made out of fire it's
incredibly proficient with these weapons
too and has a serious strategic
advantage in its underground environment
Foundation researchers have determined
that some of the wounds the Beast gained
from its first confrontation haven't
fully healed implying the Beast could in
theory be destroyed with enough
Firepower however given that the Beast
has killed almost everyone who faced it
and its mere presence can start almost
uncontrollable fires direct engagement
would only be used as a last resort even
the creature's breath can be extremely
dangerous chemical analysis of air
samples taken from SCP 1179 breath have
shown exceptionally high concentrations
of carbon monoxide and sulfur dioxide
the very presence of this creature
creates a real and active danger to
everyone around it and the Beast
presence was beginning to have seriously
negative effects on the people up above
but by the 1970s the foundation had
given up on sending mobile task forces
into the caverns and instead began to
focus on depopulating the town of
Centralia to prevent further fatalities
from the presence of SCP
1179 the Subterranean activities of the
creature were causing collapses in some
areas and noxious fumes were beginning
to Rise Up from cracks in the ground as
the constant raging fires burned beneath
the Earth they were causing everything
above to slowly melt or bake a
foundation geologist determined that the
fires created by the Beast would likely
remain active for 250 years and any
attempts to put out the fires or contain
the Beast would ultimately be futile
this led to the formation of project
Tartarus a concerted effort to cover up
SCP 1179 and fully Evacuate the citizens
of Centralia they pushed the narrative
that the mine fires while deadly were
merely the result of the failed garbage
burning plan and little by little the
people of Centralia began to move move
away by 1984 the United States
government finally caved to secret
lobbying from the foundation and
allocated funds in excess of $42 million
to relocate the remaining civilian
residents from the area any legal
complaints from Centralia residents were
quietly crushed by the foundation and
efforts to remove pretty much all
residents from the area were successful
this allowed the foundation to finally
cast a wider net and administer ker
class containment protocols around the 2
km Underground Zone where SCP 1179
resides the foundation has continued
studies on the beast from Below in the
decades since with some scientists even
suggesting it could be used to produce
geothermal energy but whether or not
that would actually be feasible remains
unknown for now SCP 1179 seems content
to stay within its Zone and hopefully it
stays that way but as we're forced to
dig deeper and deeper for the remaining
precious metals here on Earth there's no
telling what new dangers we might find
lurking far below the ground you've
finally done it after years of adding
movies and shows to your cues you've
officially run out of things to watch on
Netflix you've also exhausted your
entire backlog of books and you've even
run out of Serial boxes to read so
you're left roaming the streets in
search of entertainment that's when you
see a worn looking flyer stapled to a
nearby telephone pole it's an ad for a
local community theater production of a
play you never heard of a play called
the hanged King's tragedy normally you
wouldn't think of yourself as much of a
theater person but something about the
art on the poster grabs you there's a
strange figure on the poster its face
shrouded its body wrapped in a web of
chains your curiosity gets the better of
you and you check the performance date
to your pleasant surprise opening night
is a week from now and you don't have
anything planned you've made up your
mind you you're going to attend a live
performance of the hanged King's tragedy
it's going to be the first live play
you've ever seen and little do you know
it may also be the last because the Hang
Kings tragedy isn't just any old play
it's a powerful and deadly mimetic
Hazard that may be one of the gateways
to an even more dangerous being it's
known to the SCP Foundation as SCP 701
so take your seats be be sure to read
your programs thoroughly and prepare for
the dark and terrifying tale of the
hanged King's tragedy and the wave of
death and destruction it causes in its
theatrical wake but how could you know
any of this while you head home to make
dinner looking forward to seeing the new
plane next week the local thespians are
hard at work performing dress rehearsals
the director one Marcus Fitch happened
upon a copy of the play while looking
for Carolinian theater theer that's a
little more familyfriendly than some of
the Shakespearean Classics when he'd
first discovered the hanged King's
tragedy on a theatrical Forum it was
described as being similar to
Shakespeare's Hamlet and Titus
andronicus but the violence was largely
offstage and implied with a lot of the
plays nastier elements glossed over
perfect for audience of all ages given
the fact that performances of the Hang
King's tragedy tend to be mass casualty
events for reasons you'll soon see the
foundation does everything they can to
control the spread of the plays script
all copies are kept in a tripl locked
Vault and a secure Foundation archive
which currently includes two copies of
the original publication that are dated
to the year 1640 27 copies of the 1965
trade paperback edition 10 copies of a
1971 hard cover printing 21 floppy diset
containing the play script and one svhs
video cassette tapee containing a live
tape in of one particularly Infamous
incident however this seemingly does
little to prevent new performances of
the hanged King's tragedy from occurring
the text of the play continually pops up
online often under different or
misspelled titles preventing Foundation
web crawlers from keeping track of them
all nevertheless the foundation does
everything in its power to detect and
stop performances before they can go
ahead the danger of putting on or even
viewing a performance of the King's
tragedy cannot be overstated it's
believed that in the almost 300 years
since its original publication it's
claimed 10,000 lives through
performances at the very least and if
you're in attendance dying quickly is
one of the better outcomes the origins
of this mimic virus are just as
mysterious as the power that seems to
drive its effects the play Never Had A
declared author and the publisher one
William Cook disappeared from all
historical records after the play's
Publications performances have been
varied over the 300 years the play has
been active it's been spotted everywhere
from British University drama troops to
American High School plays in what could
have been an even more disastrous
tragedy a television adaptation of the
play was almost broadcast by the BBC
before the foundation stepped in and put
a stop to it while its containment
classification is currently uclid
scientists who have studied the have
campaigned strongly to upgrade the Hang
King's tragedy to ker class on account
of its unpredictability and tendency to
manifest across the globe with
incidences appearing decades apart while
members of the 05 Council are skeptical
some researchers even believe that given
a wide enough exposure the Hang King's
tragedy could cause a dreaded XK Class
end of the world scenario it is that
dangerous at this point you're probably
wondering what exactly is the H King's
tragedy what's the play even about as
the name suggests the play is a tragedy
and takes place over five acts during
the Carolinian era portraying the drama
of the Royal Court much like a number of
plays from that time did it takes place
in the city of cako the capital of the
mysterious fictional Kingdom of trulo
the focal point of the play is the
conflict between Gonzalo the
illegitimate king of trinko and Antonio
the true heir to the Throne before the
start of the play the previous king of
trulo King sefora had been betrayed and
murdered by Gonzalo Gonzalo LED seph
Forza into the woods where he and his
men subdued the king and hanged him from
a nearby tree like a common criminal
hence the hanged King's tragedy however
Gonzalo is trying to keep his part in
the king's murder a secret to keep the
throne for himself but his
guilt-stricken wife Isabella threatens
to Spill The Secret of Sephora's murder
while Antonio tries to uncover the truth
of what happened in the woods Gonzalo in
true Shakespearean villain style plots
further murders of his co-conspirators
and loose ends to keep his Dark Secrets
safe this is where the play gets a
little gruesome one enemy Gonzalo had
killed and cooked into a stew he then
intends to use the stew to murder his
entire court with the help of an
effective and undetectable poison he was
given by the mysterious ambassador of
alagada though you'll be pleased to know
that this tragedy has somewhat of a
happy ending in the end Gonzalo is
exposed and Antonio claims his rightful
place as king of trulo unlike his
predecessor Antonio decides to show
mercy and Gonzalo is exiled to a
monastery for life rather than being
executed for his murderous ways the
heroes are rewarded the villains are
punished and all the deserving parties
live happily ever after at face value
nothing seems awful about the play if
you're familiar with other works of the
era you might even find yourself getting
bored while reading it how can something
this normal be the curse play that
claims so many thousands of lives but
this play's unassuming nature only
serves to make it more dangerous it
doesn't appear that the mimetic hazard
is caused by simply reading the play
like all good theater it only truly
comes to life on stage and your local
production of the Hang Kings tragedy is
no exception as your community's amateur
actors study and rehearse the play
making sure to commit every scene every
line every single word to memory they
don't notice the little things that to
an outsider might seem a little off
occasionally during group dress
rehearsals actors will Veer from the
script and we're not talking about flub
lines or simple improvization no actors
will at times seem like they're reading
from a completely different script they
fellow performers will respond in kind
the play lulls you into a false sense of
security stage hands crew members even
the director all believe they're
performing the play exactly as it was
originally written okay so that's not so
bad a play that changes itself but
things are going to get worse from this
point much much worse but hey why let a
deadly anomaly ruin your evening plans
you've been looking forward to seeing
this play all week and you could didn't
seem to get that figure from the poster
out of your mind you have no idea that
this entity is wanted by the SCP
Foundation and that its designation is
SCP
71-1 all you want is an unforgettable
theater experience and you will
certainly get one it's a packed house
not an empty seed in sight the house
lights dim and the curtain opens act one
is quite normal with all the
backstabbing and Royal Court Intrigue
you'd expect you actually feel yourself
getting a little bored a big yawn
escapes your mouth you're thinking that
maybe this was a big mistake and you
might sneak out between acts when just
then you see it in the final scene of
act one you see the shrouded figure
lingering in the background against the
curtains he seems so still he's almost
like a shadow but as each actx seems to
run into the next he becomes more
prominent
the rest of the cast Never acknowledges
him as they deliver dramatic monologues
but he's always there finally the play
reached Act five the Grand Banquet scene
where it all comes to head Gonzalo is
preparing to poison his dinner guest
with his cannibal stew while Antonio and
his allies plot to reveal his terrible
crimes and Dethrone him you find
yourself so gripped by the drama of it
all you almost didn't notice that the
shrouded figure of SCP 71-1 one was
standing right among the actors now
while unbeknownst to you the actors have
been deviating from the scripted story
this whole time things are about to
really take a turn for the horrific SCP
71-1 who is now known to the other
performers as the hanged King produces a
blade from thin air and passes it to the
actor playing gonzalo's wife the actors
on stage suddenly become entranced they
attack and restrain Gonzalo and a news
drops down from somewhere above of the
stage the actors proceeded to
ritualistically hang Gonzalo before the
actor playing his wife stabs him to
death all while chanting blood for the
hanged King you should be horrified but
you're not you don't even feel like
yourself anymore and you're loving
everything that's happening on stage a
series of other newses fall from above
each actor grabs their own news and the
cast repeats blood for the hanged King
before sacrificing their lives to the
Shroud wearing monster if the Carnage
stopped there it would be bad enough but
this play doesn't just drive its players
to acts of violent Insanity it pulls in
the audience too before you know it
you're pulled into a vicious brawl with
your fellow theater goers there's biting
clawing punching people hitting each
other with chairs like it's a wrestling
cage match it's such a frenzy of random
senseless violence that the building
can't contain it anymore you and any one
else who isn't dead already Spilled Out
onto the streets and start attacking
everyone you can get your hands on it's
transformed from a pleasant night out at
the theater into a full-blown Riot even
the police sent in to control the
situation are overwhelmed it isn't until
the SCP Foundation sends a number of
mobile task forces trained in advanced
crowd control that the situation finally
begins to deescalate but you don't care
even when large men in Foundation
tactical gear are holding your arms you
still try to bite and kick the effects
of the play normally wear off after
around 24 hours but until then the
infected including you are just rage
fueled monsters in the end it takes four
adult men to properly restrain you
you'll feel the bruises from their night
sticks tomorrow but now all you feel is
hate and violence and a single-minded
Devotion to something out there that you
couldn't possibly comprehend and the
whole time you're screaming one thing
over and over again blood for the hanged
King have you ever had a nightmare that
you're running down a long dark hallway
getting chased by something you can't
see the thing behind you isn't fast but
that doesn't matter you can't run
forever and the thing knows it it is a
patient Predator it toys with its food
at first you move with speed and Rhythm
the metallic scraping noise behind you
grows quieter you run and stumble
through the dark your muscles start to
ache and your lungs burn your pace slows
it's still coming you can hear the
scraping getting louder you start to
Panic it's completely dark you don't
know where you're running or even what
you're running from all you know as you
bump against the walls and the sharp
Corners that Rush towards you is that
you can't run forever you trip fall and
pain explodes through through your legs
as your knee shatters on the concrete
ground that scraping is getting louder
you can barely breathe you can't run any
more with your injury there's no way to
stop what's coming there is no escape
the scraping is right behind you you
scream and then you wake up your heart
is pounding like thunder in your chest
and your sheets are soaked with sweat
but you're safe you're out of those
awful dark hallways but what if this
wasn't just a nightmare what if this
scenario was real and there was no
escape from the horror chasing you in
the darkness that's what it's like to
have a close encounter with SCP
1918 a sadistic sentient object that
loves playing Twisted games with its
prey but this monster never plays fair
and even worse it's always just a simple
doorway it may even be hiding behind a
door near you right now waiting to start
a game with its new playmate but soon
you'll understand why some doors should
never ever be opened and why some games
are better left unplayed SCP 1918 is an
anomaly with two parts scp1 1918 itself
and SCP
198-217 D2 are perfectly tailored to
1918s Violent Hobbies nobody knows how
long this anomaly has been operating but
it's probably behind countless
disappearances after all 1918 has a
habit of breaking its toys the nightmare
began in a small town in Maine with a
population of only 226 people but that
population was about to get lower people
in the town began to report strange
noises at night a droning metalon
concrete scraping noise like someone
dragging a lead pipe along the ground at
first people just ignored the sound it
was all in their heads or maybe just a
faulty oven or a washing machine on the
fritz anything that would allow them to
forget about the noise and get on with
their daily lives but the noises were
coming from below they could be heard
out on the streets most audibly near
manholes and Sewer grates people started
feeling unsafe in their homes the noises
were spooking animals and children
people were losing sleep that scraping
they all tried to ignore was beginning
to get to the mall letters emails and
angry phone calls to the Town Council
were piling up something had to be done
before the whole town went crazy with
fear the mayor authorized four utility
workers to investigate the source of the
noise at a local sewage treatment
facility considering the scraping was
loudest near the sewer grates everyone
just assumed that whatever was causing
all this must be connected to the sewers
four utility workers were sent to
investigate the facility only to find
that the machinery on site was working
just fine the source of the problems
must have been coming directly from the
underground sewer lines themselves the
four workers equipped with headlamps
descended into a long service tunnel
that fed into the sewer system as they
passed deeper into the tunnel the
darkness around them became thicker it
was a tangible presence that drowned out
the light of their headlamps similar to
the anomalous phenomenon exhibited by
SCP 087 when the utility workers tried
to turn back they they discovered
another impossibility it seemed that the
tunnel behind them had become a solid
concrete wall they were trapped but
where it was too dark to tell confused
and terrified the four men stuck
together attempting to find a way out it
was too dark to see their hand in front
of their face so all they could do was
navigate Slowly by feeling the walls
around them these walls felt old crusty
there was a kind of faint metallic
stench hanging in the air too like old
blood something horrible had happened
here and something horrible was about to
happen again all they could do was keep
moving and try to stay calm eventually
after hours of pawing at the walls in
the dark they found an open doorway one
by one they filed inside only to feel
blinded when bright white ceiling lights
suddenly switched on the room was all
white and filled with pipes large and
small running from wall to wall just
that then one of the utility workers let
out an earsplitting scream and pointed
towards the doorway his colleagues
turned and gasped in shock there was
something outside the door and it was
staring at them the object filled up
almost the entire doorway it seemed like
a demonic hobby horse made from a black
and white candy striped metal pole with
a crude plastic head on top the head
looked like a clowns with a wide toothy
grin but no visible eyes it was SC P
1918 the utility workers were frozen as
the object leaned forward slightly and
slithered into the room the bottom of
the metal pipe scraping against the
ground it was the exact same scraping
noise that had been haunting the
concerned towns folk up above this was
the thing behind it all and as the
object moved its metal po started to
scrape words into the ground Tick Tac
Toe none of the four utility workers
were ever seen again it didn't take long
for the SCP Foundation to descend upon
this quiet main town and pick up the
pieces all relevant officials were
provided amnestics and cover stories
were created for the disappearances of
the four utility workers the foundation
also commandeered the sewage treatment
facility that held the entrance to SCP
1918-20 was given a uclid classification
due to the fixed nature of its hunting
ground
and then the real research began the
foundation soon made some disturbing
discoveries entrances into the SCP
198-217 can be entered from almost any
location if you're unlucky enough there
are currently nine known entrances
including five sewage grates three
utility shafts located in the sewage
facility and one toilet and these are
just the ones that the foundation know
knows about there are a huge number of
ways to enter SCP
1918-20 D2 is contained 20 M below the
streets of this unassuming main Town
Personnel aside from Foundation approved
d-class guinea pigs are refused entrance
researchers have mapped out the layout
of
198-217 movements there are 18 identical
room pairs an scp1
198-217 D2 is symmetrical with half a
meter wide path circling each compound
room the only deviation to this
construction are the location of
entrances on the sides of each
individual room which vary randomly
while the location is active what
exactly does SCP 198 do in this private
little maze it plays games of course its
two favorites as indicated by the words
it scrapes into the ground are tick tac
toe and memory in tic-tac-toe 1918 moves
to each one room leaving behind X
markings on the floors if the room is
not already marked with an o in a manner
similar to a game of tic-tac-toe how a
victim is meant to accomplish making a
Mark or understanding this process is
unknown as no AIDS are given blood is
commonly used by victims to make their
markings hence the rusty smell in many
of the rooms in memory the trapped
victim is rendered unconscious by blunt
force presumably from SCP 1918 the
subject regains Consciousness in a
random section of the facility success
is marked by finding a one room
identical to the central room this event
seems to possess a time limit as the
subject is pursued by SCP 1918 through
the halls of the facility the subject
wins by marking the correct room with an
O what happens if you win or lose these
games it's important to note that scp1
1918 is very competitive and doesn't
play fair if you win the object will
merely accuse you of cheating and start
a new game this will happen again and
again until eventually you lose and what
do you do well take the horrifying
encounter d-class Personnel member D
2934 had with scp1 1918 wearing video
and audio equipment D 2934 was led into
SCP 1918 D2 by Foundation researchers
when he eventually found his way to the
central room 1918 challenged him to a
game of Tic-tac-toe and Against All Odds
D 2934 won the game but 1918 didn't take
kindly to that it accused D 2934 of
cheating carving its accusations into
the ground before challenging him to a
deadly game of memory after hours of
chasing D 2934 eventually lost his mind
and was backed into a corner by 1918 as
the object made its way towards him he
panicked ripped a pipe from the wall and
began smashing 1918s head as the plastic
cracked under the force of the blows
Foundation scientists could see real
brains inside D 2934 screamed and the
video feed cut off when the video turned
back on sometime later 1918 stair sted
into the camera with a different head
mounted at top its metal pole one that
just a few hours earlier had belonged to
the unfortunate
d2930 if there's one lesson to be
learned from this terrifying anomaly
it's that there truly Is No Escape from
SCP
1918 youve just had a night of your life
in beautiful Las Vegas Nevada you spend
hours shooting crabs dancing in clubs
and eating more than your fill at the
famous all you can eat buffets you're
staggering back to your hotel room high
on life in the early hours of the
morning when you notice something
strange a long dark tunnel just off the
side of the strip you didn't notice it
on the way in perhaps because you were
distracted by all the glitz Glamour and
hypnotic Casino lights you see the
tunnel and your overstimulated mind
feels drawn to it you stumble in and
start walking during your walk you can
feel your bones cracking they don't
shatter like you've just been hit by a
train they shift you feel the entire
shape of you bending into something
different but it doesn't stop with your
skeleton your organs start to feel
strange and then your skin in the
complete darkness of the tunnel you have
no idea what's going on so you just keep
walking eventually you find your way
into a lush green forest it's beautiful
but it feels like it should be a million
miles away from the Arid desert of
Nevada you were only in the tunnel for a
few minutes what gives hello you call
out is anybody there no answer you
explore further into this empty Forest
its trees are far as the eye can see but
no animals that's when you see something
that catches your eye a puddle of
crystal clear water but it's not the
puddle itself that draws your attention
it's what reflects back at you when you
stare into it at first you can hardly
believe it but as you move your mouth
and shock and the reflection moves its
mouth too it's suddenly all too real
you've been turned into a fox an orange
bushy tailed fox you scream and bolt all
the way back to the tunnel that led you
here you sprint through and feel your
entire body changing once more when you
finally hit the wall of dry Vegas heat
on the other side you're human again you
breathe a sigh of relief and stumble
back to your hotel room the next day you
only vaguely remember what what happened
and because you're not crazy you assume
it was just all a wild dream what you
just encountered is a uclid class SCP
known as SCP
2746 a seemingly innocent tunnel near
the Vegas Strip which holds a portal to
a Fantastical World designated by the
foundation as SCP
27461 by the time the foundation
discovered and secured the SCP 2746
tunnel and began sending their field
agents and res archers on fact finding
Expeditions inside the place was already
a ghost town a forested land mass
approximately 111 km in diameter with no
notable Signs of Life the foundation
discovered that this place had a strange
effect on people and animals who came in
from our world humans who entered
assumed the form of a random animal but
retained their intelligence and vocal
cords creating talking animals animals
brought into
27461 retained their animalistic
intelligence but grew human-like vocal
cords allowing them to repeat simple
phrases before the mass Exodus or
Extinction event that left
27461 Baron the foundation figured out
that this place was populated by a whole
civilization of intelligent animals like
something out of a fairy tale these
animals through a mix of brains and
Magic were able to leave written records
and create impressive architecture like
homes and places of worship Foundation
researchers became fascinated with how
exactly this Society operated and what
could have led to its sudden downfall
thanks to a mix of advanced archaeology
and Records left behind by the creatures
this is what the foundation determined
the society these talking intelligent
animals lived in was a kind of religious
oligarchy meaning power was Consolidated
by the few in the top social class
Society was divided into three segments
Crafters Scholars and honorables with
the Crafters being the most powerful
members of of society and honorables
being the least powerful the state
sponsored churches acted in worship of a
being simply called the maker who fills
a similar role to the abrahamic god the
Crafters whose number total 13 were
believed to be immortal and were
responsible for building the majority of
the culture and architecture found in
27461 the scholars acted as their wise
assistance and the honorables were a
mixed class of artists carpenters and
artisans it seemed that this culture had
a pretty good thing going no system of
currency was ever invented and the
economy operated on a barter system the
foundation believes that initially the
citizens of this world didn't need to
eat to survive and so only needed to
barter for material Goods though it's
worth noting that the conditions of
immortality only apply to natives of
this region people born on Earth but
assuming animal forms while entering
27461 still need nutrition to survive
however a great tragedy soon caused a
fundamental shift in the balance of life
and Society within
27461 the maker decided it wanted to
test or punish its subjects with two
major changes first humans would be
forbidden from entering the domain and
second the maker now made the
consumption of food necessary for
continued survival and Sanity nothing
was ever the same because nobody had
needed to eat prior to this food stores
had never been made and the inhabitants
had no agricultural knowledge that would
allow them to easily mass-produce more
as a result while the crafters and
Scholars were able to feed on fruits
from luxurious private Gardens the
honorables were forced to resort to
eating each other or other inhabitants
of
27461 this began a bloody Rift that
split Society from the top down one half
led by the powerful Crafters sari and
suard wanted to preserve society as it
was and continued to worship the maker
sari took the form of a Flemish giant
rabbit and Seward appeared as a houseat
the opposition led by former Crafters
Frederick and agathos with The Reluctant
help of a scholar named Clovis wanted to
get revenge on the maker for all he'd
done and kill him completely altering
Society don't be fooled by their
appearances though many of the
inhabitants of
27461 were fiercely intelligent
Sorcerers and the apocal itic Civil War
they sparked came to be known to the
foundation as event Nash like many wars
there would be no real winners here only
survivors and even then not for long it
was a bloody and horrific War all
attempts at finding a diplomatic
solution failed Frederick and agathos
would not stop until they had the
maker's blood on their paws in the end
though they were defeated and for their
traitorous crimes they were to be
punished by s and Seward in horrific
ways to make examples of them since
neither could die they were given Fates
worse than death instead Frederick was
up first before the war he'd been a
leader prize for his courage and
Ingenuity he created something known as
the great fire which provided the
kingdom with light for his so-called
atrocities against the maker he was
given the punishment of permanent
crucifixion and relocation to a place
known as the under plane his snout was
cut off his face and he was set
permanently Ablaze in a manner that
would leave him forever suffering and
would make him appear to look like a
monster to all next went agathos she was
Frederick's sister and was seen as The
Mastermind of many of their schemes she
would be forever encased in white clay
and bled through her eyes until the sin
drains from her she's now a living
crying statue existing in a state of
permanent imprisonment for her part in
the crimes against the maker Clovis
because her involvement in the coupe was
unwilling was given a more minor
punishment one of her eyes was removed
and she was permanently placed in a
broken human body effectively banishing
her from her home in
27461 forever though they may have won
things didn't end much better for SAR
and cro the Civil War had fractured
their world and in the aftermath the
survivors chose to leave in hopes of
finding a better life elsewhere Zari and
SEO though felt partially responsible
for everything that had happened and so
they decided to remain in their Dying
World before they themselves died or
perhaps moved on to different forms
leaving their animal bodies behind they
left a final note it was from this note
that the foundation learned much of the
story of SCP
2746 this may seem like a pretty open
and shut case another magical realm
destroyed by tragedy and Civil War much
like the land of fantasy and SCP
1762 but what's really bizarre here is
that this is only the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to the stories of some of
these key figures in the event nahash
first what became of the two Rebels
agathos and Frederick today they're two
parts of the feared and deadly SCP 1913
Frederick now going by Freddy is a
nightmarish faceless fire demon in the
form of a dog slavishly devoted to the
protection of of his sister agathos now
known as Agatha still trapped in white
clay her leaking blood now deadly to the
touch Clovis is still believed to be in
League with agathos and Frederick and
may now be related to the Sinister SCP
1903 a oneeyed rabbit-like human but
strangest of all is the possible truth
behind SAR and seor the two devotees to
the maker who remained in
27461 until their very last breath
breath in all likelihood these two were
once agents of the SCP foundation's
Infamous Las Vegas Branch they took on
these more animalistic forms after their
deaths sari may have once been agent
sarak Crowley a Japanese American woman
who died in the line of duty in 1960
Seward was once Dr Stuart Hayward cley's
partner his new name acting as a kind of
fusion of the first and last name he had
in life this is only the beginning of
the animal themed weirdness occurring
around site 45 the foundation's Vegas
Branch but this series of anomalies
collected under the term pitch Haven
we'll have to wait for another video
after all you know what they say what
happens in Vegas stays in Vegas you're
driving down a long Highway lost in an
area you don't know too well trying to
find the right turn that'll have you
heading back towards your home you keep
driving the nighttime quiet all around
you deciding to try and break that
silence you reach for the radio turning
the dial to filter through all the
garbled distorted voices and songs from
nearby local radio stations that are too
far out of range to come through clearly
you try your best to listen to the music
from One radio station but eventually
the sound of the static only makes you
wish for the silence you were trying to
break your fingers nudge the tuning dial
on your car radio once again and finally
something comes through it isn't loud or
clear but under the Distortion you can
make out the sound and it isn't a song
or even a late news broadcast the first
thing you hear sounds like a short
musical tone only for about 10 seconds
next a young girl's voice speaking in a
language you don't understand even
through the distorted audio from her
accent you assume it's Russian but you
still have no idea what the word she's
saying mean with nothing else to listen
to to you let the broadcast play still
driving alone in the dark with nothing
but the strange adolescent voice to
accompany you your mind begins to wander
she sounds like she's speaking something
but the rhythm of the words is somehow
familiar to you even though you don't
speak Russian then it hits you she's
counting but you don't feel smart for
having worked that out instead something
about knowing that makes your blood run
cold you carry on driving through the
night after a few short minutes the
Russian girl stops counting and the
musical tone plays again under the
Distortion leaving you alone in the car
once again with nothing but your
thoughts and questions of what exactly
you just heard thankfully we have the
answer what you heard was SCP 3034 since
1964 this same broadcast has been made a
vast number of times 627 times in fact
you'd have to be within 2 km of the
broadcast point of origin to hear it
where Foundation Personnel have tried
and failed numerous times to triangulate
its source the numbers heard recited in
the SCP 3034 broadcast are actually a
countdown from 200 read aloud in Russian
all Foundation staff are able to do
while stationed at the nearby
provisional site 3034 is scour radio
frequencies for occurrences of SCP 3034
checking their equipment is properly
maintained and calibrated before they
are eventually rotated off site and
replaced with a new group of staff there
is only one rule that any foundation
members working at provisional site 3034
must follow they are only permitted to
send one radio transmission with their
equipment a single phrase in reply to
the SCP 3034 broadcast vior Haru
receiving this the countdown stops and
the broadcast ends but never permanently
SCP 3034 has been known to repeatedly
occur seemingly at random the shortest
recorded gap between broadcasts was 2
weeks while the longest so far lasted
six whole months you may have heard the
term num station mentioned before but
these are far from just random numerical
sequences sent out over the airwaves
without purpose General speculation
surrounding number stations points to
them being the tools of Espionage agents
a way of sending coded highly sensitive
messages or information without the risk
of compromising their cover the use of
number station Transmissions is often
attributed to spies working on foreign
soil who utilize shortwave radio
frequencies speech synthesis Morse code
and either regular or sporadic timing
schedules while it's true that times
have changed and technology has
progressed considerably there appears to
be evidence that number stations are
still used among various intelligence
and Espionage agencies today despite
being considered an old-fashioned method
of communication these lowtech shortwave
stations remain a viable reliable option
for the transmission and reception of
intelligence to field agents the conet
project is a comprehensive Archive of
this phenomenon and its founder Aken
Fernandez has long been fascinated by
number stations according to him this
system is completely secure because the
messages can't be tracked the recipient
could be anywhere you just send spies to
the country and get them to buy a radio
they know where to tune and when so what
does the distorted broadcast of numbers
from SCP 3034 mean is it the work of
covert agents and if so whose side are
they on most importantly why does the
SCP Foundation make certain there are
always three of its Personnel on site
ready to send the all aswell message
whenever SCP 3034 begins broadcasting
SCP 3034 was first discovered by the
foundation in
1964 after a def protector from the
Soviet grup a division tasked with
acquiring and studying anomalies on
behalf of the USSR gave them a tip
Commander Robert malus along with a team
of six including a man named agent
Browning selected for his knowledge of
Russian dialects were sent to
investigate at provisional site 3034
here the team uncovered partially burned
records and log books all kept in
Russian along with evidence that the
site had been evacuated shortly before
their arrival carved into a desk also in
Russian were two phrases don't let her
finish and tell her all is well on the
team's second day at the site an
automated alarm sounded at 7:30 a.m.
alerting them to the incoming SCP 3034
broadcast following the instructions on
the desk agent Browning was able to stop
the broadcast telling the young Russian
girl that all was well a tape was
partially recovered by the team from the
site and translated from Russian the
grup members that had previously
inhabited the station had interrogated
one of their own a man named Sergey whom
they accused of stealing State Property
she's not State Property he replied she
has in name while his grup Superior
accused Sergey of planning to defect to
the United States allegedly in exchange
for money and Asylum Sergey denied any
collusion with America he claimed that
the grup at provisional site 3034 were
meddling with powers they could not
possibly hope to understand his Superior
a man named voff dismissed this claiming
their work to be no different to the
United States experimentation with
atomic weapons at the time one does not
make deals with atom bombs Sergey argued
one certainly does not sacrifice little
girls to them shortly after this a
struggle broke out with Sergey having to
be restrained while urging vaslov to
cease any and all interference with it
the man spoke of terrible nightmares
that he'd had voices screaming in the
darkness that's what he wants V love
that's what it is you cannot make a deal
with this te we have finally contained
it and now you want to offer it the
tapes audio ends shortly after this
point with no clear answer as to what
Sergey was referring to or what offer
these Russian operatives had made to it
ever since the discovery of SCP 3034
members of the SCP Foundation have
worked tirelessly to understand the
purpose of these countdowns as well as
determine their origin by September 2012
Dr kill was reaching the end of his
tether with the investigation into the
SCP 3034 broadcast over almost half a
century the foundation had made well
over 600 recordings of the Russian girls
countdowns but still hadn't determined
any noteworthy information they were
prohibited from contacting the girl via
the same radio frequency only permitted
to use the phrase that stopped her
countdowns running out of options schul
kill contacted his colleague Dr Emerson
asking for an in-depth VOC local
analysis of the various recordings of
SCP
3034 even if they could narrow down
where the broadcast was coming from
Maybe by determining the girl's
geographical location from her dialect
then that would be at least some slight
progress into understanding SCP 3034
while unable to discover the girl's
location Dr Emerson's analysis did yield
some interesting findings Emerson
learned that these countdowns were not
pre-recorded the variations in the
russing girl's voice her tone her pitch
all seemed to indicate that every
instance of the broadcast was unique
rather than use the same recording this
girl had been counting down over and
over hundreds of times for almost 50
years but there was more schul kill and
Emerson then examined the Distortion The
Sounds interfering with the audio of the
rushan girls countdowns what had
initially seemed like garbled static
seemed to actually be additional voices
and much like the girl's voice these
distorted voices were unique different
in every broadcast however shill and
Emerson were unable to accurately
determine what these voices were saying
given that the girls countdowns were
always cut short by the use of the
phrase all is well the doctors did not
have long enough samples of the audio to
analyze the other distorted voices with
permission from the foundation the next
five occurrences of the SCP 3034
broadcast were allowed to carry on for
longer giv giving the two doctors enough
audio to determine exactly what the
distorted voices were and the results
were extremely troubling they were
screams thousands upon thousands of
children's voices endlessly screaming
both Dr Emerson and Dr schill agreed
that it would be best to continue
responding to SCP 3034 with the correct
phrase and refused to analiz the
distorted screaming audio any further 3
years later while stationed at
provisional site 3034 a foundation
researcher named Dr Uriel Willis decided
to take matters into her own hands she
conducted an experiment that had not
been sanctioned by the foundation and
attempted to make contact with the
Russian girl giving the countdowns
hearing Dr Willis's voice the girl
stopped her countdown after five long
painfully silent seconds a new broadcast
was heard a piercing high-pitch Screech
that caused extreme pain and dizziness
to all the staff working on site unable
to Bear the disorienting sound Dr Willis
told the girl all is well and caused the
noise to stop the following day SCP
researchers noted that there had been a
significant increase in cases of missing
children all around the world a majority
of these disappearances happened at the
same time the Screech had been broadcast
and remain unsolved to this day Dr
Willis faced disciplinary action from
the SCP Foundation and any further
testing of SCP 334 and attempts to
communicate with the Russian girl were
prohibited only one distinct change has
been noted in the SCP 334 broadcast
since this incident almost a month later
the countdown was detected and the
correct phrase given but researchers
noted that instead of starting her
countdown from 200 this time the Russian
girl began counting down from
199 nobody knows what will happen if the
Russian girls countdown is allowed to
reach zero Personnel working at oral
site 3034 are told to always offer her
the necessary phrase before this point
in the countdown attempting to interfere
with the broadcast by contacting this
girl directly not only resulted in
intense pain for SCP staff but also
seems to have caused an unconfirm number
of child disappearances around the globe
as well as reducing the countdown
starting number from 200
to9 after a long night on the road you
finally find the right turn sending you
in the the right direction as you drive
through the night you keep telling
yourself one thing one small phrase over
and over again you hope the words will
eventually give you comfort but deep
down you start to realize just how
hollow they are that it's just a lie we
tell ourselves so we don't have to face
the inevitable but still what choice do
you have but to keep telling yourself
that all is well Dr Lola Bergman was an
accomplished senior researcher for for
the SCP Foundation her years of hard
work studying anomalies and dedication
to the foundation had earned her a level
three security clearance allowing her to
access a bevy of secret information
across the foundation's vast Network as
a researcher and a scientist Dr Bergman
was the naturally inquisitive type she
wanted to know everything there was to
know about the strange and esoteric
Universe around her that's why when she
heard about the file for SCP 2000 one of
the organization's best kept secrets she
was hooked the only problem was that
just to view the file you had to be on
the 05 Council or have a special subset
of level four clearance known as 42000
unfortunately Dr Bergman was only a
level three but you know what they say
the forbidden fruit always tastes the
sweetest Dr Bergman had given the
foundation years of service what could
the harm be in breaking the rules and
getting a peak behind the curtain just
this once through somewhat deceptive
means Dr Bergman managed to get her
hands on some 42000 clear credentials
and decided to access the file on an
encrypted personal device they'd never
even know but as she entered the
credentials she found herself suddenly
looking at an image on its face nothing
an image of a dirt road in a field with
tiny white text reading remember us but
this was a powerful Cognito hazardous
image capable of causing immediate
incapacitation the next thing she knew
she was laying on the ground unconscious
when she woke up she was no longer a
doctor at the CP Foundation she was on a
street corner unable to remember her own
name let alone her history all she could
do was murmur something about a secret
under Yellowstone National Park Dr
bergman's years of service had meant
nothing in the end SCP 2000 is an
anomalous asset so vital to not only the
foundation but the entire world that so
much as attempting to access it without
the proper clearance leads to immediate
termination but what's really hidden
under Yellowstone National Park and why
are the foundation hups so intent on
keeping it secret even from most of
their own ranks of course Yellowstone
National Park itself is no stranger to
anomalous activity the entire National
Park is technically an SCP known as SCP
1422 while it since has been neutralized
SCP 1422 caused all members of the SCP
Foundation to have no awareness of
Yellowstone National Park prior to 2007
but the true nature of SCP 2000 the
secret hidden under Yellowstone National
Park is not only Stranger Than SCP
1422 but also depending on your
perspective either profoundly relieving
or utterly terrifying but before you can
truly understand the purpose and gravity
of SCP 2000 or the Deo exmachina we need
to talk about the end of the world in
Foundation parland k-class scenarios are
events which have drastic implications
on the state of society normality or
even life the most dangerous and feared
of all of these are XK class scenarios
which are for all intents and purposes
the apocalypse there are a worrying
number of anomalies capable of bringing
about an XK class scenario if the
foundation ever dropped the ball on
their protection or containment while
the foundation believes that prevention
is always preferable to the Cure what
happens when prevention doesn't work
what happens when our worst fears are
realized and the end truly comes for us
all the answer is s CP 2000 happens
simply put the anomaly is a reset button
a chance to start over when all life has
been compromised by anomalous activity
2000 is a giant and mysterious facility
beneath Yellowstone National Park the
entrance is disguised as a disused park
ranger station feeding into a facility
that burrows miles down into the Earth
it's a place that contains incredible
anomalous Technologies capable of
bringing the world back to its former
glory even after the worst happens only
a select few Personnel are allowed to
work at the facility keeping its
Machinery maintained in case the day
comes where we ever need to use it again
these Personnel are not allowed to come
and go as they please and their memories
of 2000 are wipe if they're ever
reassigned to different Foundation
duties elsewhere why all the secrecy SCP
2000 is the foundation's and hum's
lifebo and as such the base is well
guarded both from potential human
threats as well as anomalous activity
and reality warpers the surface level
entrance to the base is surrounded by a
number of strategically placed Scranton
reality anchors or sras these devices
largely constructed of corrosion
resistant burum bronze alloy keep
certain type of reality bending
anomalies from manifesting their powers
within the vicinity of the base however
these are just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to the state-of-the-art
Foundation Technology employed within
and around SCP 2000 you probably have a
lot of questions and that's
understandable what kind of Technology
can possibly reverse an apocalypse and
what did we mean when we said we may
need to use it again well listen up
because this is going to be a lot to
take in SCP 2000 is powered by a liquid
fluoride thorium reactor stabilized by
five zank anastasios constant temporal
sinks and host to the most miraculous
technology of all 500,000 bright Zaron
hominoid replicators utilizing
geothermal energy from the volcanic
activity in the area the base could
potentially remain operational forever
if Foundation staff kept up with
maintenance the grand majority of the
space in this huge Subterranean facility
is taken up by Building Materials
construction equipment Factory Machinery
agricultural equipment and computer
database storage why well let's explain
the process of the apocalypse and how it
relates to the activities of SCP 2000 in
any k-class or endof thee World scenario
that doesn't destroy SCP 2000 in the
process any surviving Foundation member
can enact procedure cya 009 while any
foundation facilities globally can
monitor the unfolding situation while
SCP 2000 is waiting for the all clear to
do its thing remaining Foundation sides
set in motion what is known as the ganam
protocol this involves collecting and
preserving materials which could be
useful during the recreation process
however it's extremely possible that in
a sudden XK class endof thee World
scenario there may be no surviving
Foundation personnel or at least not
enough to maintain any kind of
organization thankfully there are
failsafe measures for such a scenario
during the periods of extended inaction
caused by an apocalypse that destroys
most human life SCP 2000 will gradually
autonomously relax its security measures
any Personnel regardless of clearance
will be able to activate the next stage
of the process when this occurs if such
a thing doesn't happen for an extended
period the security measures lapse
further to the point that even the
presence of an animal could activate it
this would set into motion procedure
Lazarus 01 Humanity's Last Hope for
survival that's where the 500,000 bright
Zaron hominoid replicators or bhrs come
in these incredible pieces of anomalous
technology are capable of perfectly
cloning the entire human race from any
given period in the last 20 years even
down to their ages and memories thanks
to class G hallucinogens and
developmental hypnotherapy with a
warm-up period of 5 days
these machines are capable of creating
100,000 viable non-anomalous humans per
day the facility keeps records of all
known human alals and is capable of
recreating any lost human genomes or
generating as many new and unique
genomes as necessary to repopulate human
civilization which humans the machines
generate depends on the period of time
the machine is ordered to replicate it
will first reproduce prominent cultural
and political figures as well as the
acting top brass of the SCP Foundation
to coordinate the creation effort of
course the machine will then recreate
well everyone else you're probably
wondering if the world outside SCP 2000
has been destroyed then what good is
creating all these new humans if they
have nothing to go back to thankfully
SCP 2000 has a contingency for
rebuilding both the infrastructure of
civilization as well as Society itself
the first generation clones will have
one Mission rebuild and they will have
quite literally all the resources in the
world to do it in addition to having all
the physical equipment for buildings and
agriculture SCP 2000 stores an immense
amount of data which is appropriate
considering the whole facility is
basically a huge backup drive for life
itself they have the entire internet
backed up as well as the sum of all
human memory and a wide cultural base
with copies of thousands of famous works
of art music and literature they have
all the scattered jigsaw pieces of the
time that came before and it's their job
to put the whole thing back together
it's expected that many of the first
generation of clones will die in this
process but that's fine with the bcrs
working at full capacity anyone can be
replicated as the population increases
and spreads across the globe rebuilding
and recolonizing old settlements
population growth will increase
exponentially once Society returns to
some kind of normal decades after the
activation of procedure Lazarus 01 it
becomes the foundation's task to restore
the psychological and historical status
quo administrators will falsify dendr
chronological astronomical and
radiometric dating records to make it
seem as though history never paused
they'll then employ amnestic agent nu5
and Mass to erase and reconstruct the
memories of the entire human population
up until the chosen time prior to the
end of the world as far as civilization
knows nothing ever happened history
never stopped and life goes on it may
seem comforting at first to know that
the ultimate contingency is out there
even if there's a containment breach of
astronomical proportions and the World
As We Know It Ends there's still a way
out it means that there's hope even in
the bleakest situations but of course
there are always cats after all if a
deal seems too good to be true it's safe
to assume it probably is whether any of
this works is dependent on two factors
the first is that no anomalies or human
insurgents Infiltrate The SCP 20 000
facility and destroy the equipment
within it's for this reason that
discussion of the facility is so
restrictive if ever a powerful reality
warper discovered and gained access to
the facility we would lose our
lifebo the second factor is the overall
Integrity of the machines after all
without proper maintenance it's not hard
for the technology to malfunction often
to truly horrifying results the failure
of some s and xax components is believed
to have caused erroneous bzr activity
resulting in the production of 10
million humanoid entities with internal
biology wildly inconsistent with
Humanity these beings remained
unconscious for 5 weeks before dying in
the event of an XK class endof thee
World scenario well-maintained machines
can reproduce the human race but all it
take is one little malfunction to
release 10 million mutants who are
effectively Dead on Arrival even with
SCP 2000 in our back pocket the fate of
the world still lives on a knife's ed
Edge but in a way that's not even the
most frightening part of the existence
of SCP 2000 seeing as the machine can
perfectly reproduce reality without
leaving a trace behind it raises the
question how many times has this
happened you may be surprised but the
foundation can confirm this occurred at
least twice in recorded history but can
you ever really be sure of how many
times your clone has crawled out of the
bzr we received a disturbing clue to the
reality of the situation when human
remains were discovered on site at SCP
2000 all tests indicate that the remains
are between 450 and 700 years old and
have been matched to the very much alive
Dr Alto cleff who has no knowledge of
how these remains came to be there the
only other thing found within the
remains was a note hermetically sealed
in a plastic document sleeve the note
read why do we have to build this thing
when did we do it how long have we been
doing it do we even know and the answer
no we don't and for everyone's peace of
mind it's probably best to just forget
about it if you can Ching haai Lake the
largest lake in China is one of the most
secure locations thep Foundation has
ever taken control of all available
military assets have been gathered at
the site including three of the most
elite mobile task force units with
experimental Weaponry SCP 4290 must not
allowed to open and the site has been
surrounded by nuclear mines and targeted
with the dagas break orbital strike
system the perimeter cannot be breached
even if it means the complete
annihilation of the entire area this is
considered to be an acceptable loss for
the foundation since the destruction
that would be caused by taking such an
extreme measure is far from the worst
case scenario when it comes to SCP
4290 that's because the entity contained
within SCP 42 90 site has the potential
to create a true end of the world
scenario the foundation of course is no
stranger to such situations and even has
a set of designations for the various
types of apocalypses like CK class
restructuring scenarios and ZK Class end
of reality scenarios and since dealing
with the end of the world is nothing new
for the foundation certain precautions
have been taken at the 4290 site if
containment measures fail selected
Foundation personnel and civilians will
be taken into nearby Emergency Shelters
that will hopefully survive the chaos
that would occur following a breach and
the foundation assumed that there was a
good chance this plan would have to be
used at some point since at the time
these precautions were put in place it
was impossible to know the chance of
successful long-term containment but
just what is the entity that is held
within the site of SCP 4290 that is
capable of causing so Much Death and
destruction on a major scale they call
it simply the child no one has ever seen
the child no one knows what the entity
is that's because even setting aside all
the foundation security the site itself
is still deeply protected literally over
100 feet below the surface of Ching haai
Lake a stunning collection of relics can
be found the site is theurgic sealed
with eight massive metal totems made of
burum and bronze that resemble armed
Warriors the statues are are inscribed
with ruins and arranged in a pattern
designed to banish The Entity kept there
and keep the seal on its prison closed
archaeological evidence indicates that
the site has been there for a very long
time and it is still active with the
center of the site periodically emitting
bursts of red light but lately the
bursts have suddenly started getting
brighter you may be wondering how we
know so much about SCP 4290 and that
it's a site designed to keep something
sealed if it's been deep in a lake
quietly doing its job the SCP Foundation
has access to unusual sources including
SCP
1726 and it's from there that we learned
the little we know about SCP
4290 SCP 1726 is a library in China that
appears to only be one floor from the
outside but on the inside covers over 14
Square km in area it's full of a
seemingly Limitless amount of texts many
of which describe ancient and lost
civilizations
along with some Clues as to what led to
the fall of these cultures one text
reveals the presence of a terrible and
apparently Unstoppable enemy it was
called the child but it was anything but
innocent when these texts were
translated what Foundation researchers
discovered terrified them they described
the emergence of a beast with 10
terrible mouths and 20 arms stretched
wine it was attacked by an army of
Warriors but they were quickly
overwhelmed by what was described as
Torrance of darkness and dead geometries
they were killed brutally and the child
used its skeletal fingers to unleash a
torrent of flame every soul in the
vicinity was consumed wax rained from
the sky and the child devoured
everything around it for 10 days as the
whole world trembled but then something
sealed the child away in its prison
which is now covered By the Waters of
Ching haai Lake soon ominous signs began
to appear that the child would awaken
again though one day televisions in the
nearby area all suddenly stopped playing
their regular programming and began to
show images of SCP 4290 with a
mysterious voice coming on over the
images saying repair the child's locks
this became more and more frequent and
the tone of the voice became more
worried eventually saying there is
little time left further investigations
of the location revealed the location of
the mysterious mechanism that kept the
chamber sealed which was designated as
SCP 4290 lock but how do you repair a
device that is eon's old and should you
even be fixing it when the one telling
you to do so is a mysterious disembodied
voice that only appears on pirated
television broadcasts the foundation
scrambled to find any information they
could and they were able to find clues
about the history of SCP 4290 referenced
in other texts lost civilizations like
the Sha Dynasty the xans and the ancient
oroni had apparently strengthened the
seals during their own Reigns but the
most significant findings indicated a
connection to one of the most terrifying
entities the SCP Foundation had ever
contained and one of the most
unpredictable the dvit Empire this
mysterious warlike civilization has only
been known through one source SCP 140 a
single hard copy book titled A Chronicle
of Davos this this is a strange
anomalous book that is Written in Blood
and is able to add more pages
spontaneously to itself whenever it
comes in contact with any fluid that can
be used for writing but seems to
especially prefer human blood it
recounts the history of this
civilization and there many brutal
conquests while there was no proof of
the DeVos before the book was found
evidence paralleling the events written
in the book is now being found in
archaeological digs more dangerously as
more pages appear in the book The the
events of the DVA Empire are moving
closer to present day with them
currently appearing in the book as
having existed until 270s CE the Davos
were a bloodthirsty brutal race of
Warriors but there was one thing even
they were afraid of the child the Davos
had performed the last successful ritual
of sacrifice needed to strengthen the
lock not long before their currently
described destruction and the book
contained enough detail to recreate the
ritual but SCP researchers would find
that performing it would not be for the
faint of har the ritual required three
human cavers not a problem for an
organization that's normal day-to-day
operation results in the loss of
multiple lives and the live Heart Of An
Angel the description of the ritual said
that the materials would be presented
new ruins should be carved into the
totems the items would then vanish when
the ritual was completed and the lock
would somehow be renewed by this it
wasn't much to go on but time was
running out the foundation's department
of occult containment quickly sprang
into action assembling the materials and
placing them in the correct formation
while it was not safe to descend that
deep underwater to perform the ritual
manually technology could fill the role
a fleet of remotely operated
submersibles equipped with carving
material would carry the materials and
perform the ritual without any human
hands needed one of the red burst
occurred Midway through the ritual
causing radiation damage to the vehicles
runes that have been car carved in the
past were also damaged and the ritual
was interrupted while it seemed like it
might have been enough to activate the
site it wasn't perfect and when the
ritual was complete one of the three
cadavers and half of the Angel Heart
were still present at the site had it
been enough to satisfy the ritual and
resealed the lock there was nothing to
do but wait and see they wouldn't have
to wait long for their answer as the
mysterious Voice once again took over
the televisions in the area this time
its message was less friendly the
sacrifice did not reach the 10 MOS brace
the child apparently was not satisfied
and the lock was not sealed everyone
feared it was too late to prevent what
was coming and panic was starting to
spread among the ranks one day several
Personnel stationed at the changhai lake
site broke protocol and fled none of
them were ever found but one fugitive
staff member an agent Zenovia marinos
left behind a note though it read do we
think we can actually stop this no
civilization before us wanted to fight
the child none of them the sacrifices
won't work anymore it refuses to consume
them they aren't enough to satiate it
once the seal breaks we'll have a world
of molten darkness and the child will be
all that's left eating drinking your
fools for staying agent marinos was
apparently so scared that she had fled
through a portal to an extra dimensional
space in order to escape there would be
no point in trying to track her even if
she was still alive but in her own
dimension
time was running out Foundation
seismologists were brought to the site
and stationed outside and began
monitoring the high energy pulses coming
from behind the lack the energy was
reportedly strong enough to alter
dimensions and the pulsing red light now
covered the entire ceiling site growing
stronger and stronger as the totems
started degrading at an alarming rate
the foundation stood on guard for
whatever was about to emerge but no one
knew if they had any chance against
whatever it was on August August 18th
the totems fully disintegrated some of
the foundation's best military forces
gathered on the shores of the lake and
waited 10 minutes later something
massive emerged phase out of the lock
and onto the sea and didn't move the
assembled Foundation forces were
confused and continued to observe the
creature and after no activity was seen
after 3 hours the authorization was
given for submersibles and a small
exploratory team to proceed down to the
seabed for an up close investigation
there down on the floor of the lake was
the child it was as terrifying as
described with a countless mouths and
arms and huge in size over 40 m long the
signs of previous rituals were
everywhere with angel hearts and human
corpses littered around some in the
creatur's mouth but none of them had
been eaten the ritual had apparently
been performed many times but to no
actual purpose the massive being was
scanned many times but no sign of
psychic energy radiation or other life
signs were detected the child was dead
and it had apparently been so for a very
very long time once the area had been
cleared teams were brought in to
investigate the body in person and
perform an autopsy on site no
explanation of what exactly this
creature had been or what its Origins
were has ever been discovered but they
did get answers for when it died the
time of death was roughly 9,000 years
ago not long after its initial ceiling
the cause of death was discovered too
the child destroyer of worlds and
Scourge of countless civilizations had
died from malnutrition whatever this
thing had been it had been sealed away
and had died from Hunger not long after
one civilization after another had
continued to perform the rituals to keep
its sealed never aware that it was no
longer a threat with this new discovery
SCP 4290 was reclassified as neutralized
but the child taught us all a valuable
lesson about being prepared for
potential world-ending scenarios and the
foundation continues to stand on alert
for any more entities from the distant
past that may pose a threat today
because who knows what else is sealed
away at the bottom of a lake abandoned
mind or in the ocean's deepest trenches
there might just be another existential
threat to humanity that's just waiting
for a chance to emerge and help us all
if it remembered to pack a lunge what
would you trade in order to make your
deepest desires a reality how much would
you be willing to barter in order to
have what you want whether it's money
love fame or power that you crave would
you bargain your soul to have it how
about your memories what about the life
of another person if these questions
Intrigue you then boy do we have the
deal of a lifetime for you well not us
but rather a certain anomaly who's very
very very interested in the art of the
deal we've all heard the old adage of a
deal with the devil meaning a PCT with
someone potentially Shady in order to
get what you want not only are you
compromising your own principles when
you make a deal like this you're also
running the risk of that deal coming
back to haunt you when it's time to pay
the devil his dues and believe us the
devil always comes to collect of course
you've never made a deal with the actual
devil and if you had it's likely you
wouldn't live long enough to warn people
not to make the same mistake but we've
all heard the Legends bezel buub
appearing to those in dire need of help
and offering them salvation shaking that
outstretched clawed hand normally
results in the desperate person getting
what they need but also agreeing to give
Satan something along the lines of their
soul or firstborn child or sometimes
something even worse the point being
that dealing with the devil often
extracts a heavy price and one you might
not be so willing to pay if you could
see the terms more clearly which brings
us to SCP 738 also known as the devil's
deal although this SCP has no relation
to the actual biblical Lord of Darkness
himself as far as we know anyway that
nickname should paint a very clear
picture for you of how this entity
operates kept in three linked
containment Chambers SCP 738 is guarded
at all times by armed Foundation
Personnel when not in use strangely for
an anomaly with such a terrifying
reputation it appears as an elegant
three-piece set of furniture the kind
you might find in a fancy office
belonging to a slick CEO the set
consists of a desk one straight back
chair and another more extravagant
office chair styled to look like a
throne all featuring brass detailing and
exquisite velvet padding in a deep Royal
Purple when kept apart these objects
seem to be little more than just
expensive pieces of office furniture
examples of quality craftsmanship that
would likely cost you an arm and a leg
to afford but nothing overtly Sinister
or anomalous until that is the three
pieces are put together and you take a
seat if someone sits down opposite the
throne within the desk between them then
they had best be ready to bargain
because once you sit down you will find
yourself faced with an anomalous entity
across from you on the throne while many
of the DCL classes the foundation has
placed before this entity have described
it as being Charming or even seductive
descriptions of the entity's appearance
varies wildly between subjects in fact
it would seem that the entity
deliberately appears differently to
everyone that sees it their very own
personalized Devil with which to strike
a deal after all this business is
personal Additionally the entity cannot
be observed by anyone except for those
sitting in the anomalous chair of SCP
738 for anyone not sitting in the
special chair the most see of the entity
is the throne shifting as it leans
backwards or sits up it isn't interested
in being seen by anyone who isn't part
of the transaction this entity is cly
quite the negotiator and doesn't waste
any time in getting to the meat of the
conversation during tests by the
foundation recordings have been made of
the entity's voice making all manner of
enticing offers and Promises to whomever
is sitting before it the entity will
produce parchment from the desk writing
up what looks to be a contract with a
quill and ink pot if whomever is sitting
in the opposite chair makes a formal
request to The Entity it will cease its
previous barrage of offers and take a
brief pause before suggesting a price
during their first attempt to gauge the
nature and effects of SCP 738 the
foundation sent one of its researchers
into a room containing the desk throne
and chair according to his report he saw
a man sitting behind the desk wearing a
sharp red and gold colored business suit
The Entity immediately bombarded the man
with potential Deals they could strike
offering him greater recognition and
respect for his research the love of the
woman the man wanted and even offering
him the chance to join the 05 council
refusing to be coerced into any of these
deals the researcher left the room and
seemed to suffer no adverse effects for
his refusal since this initial incident
when testing the behavior and effects of
SCP 738 the foundation primarily uses
d-class personnel as we all know by now
these Personnel are considered
disposable having been recruited from
prisons around the world and ones
testing SCP 738 are fitted with an
explosive collar just in case in one
instance one of these class D Personnel
placed before the SCP 738 entity
reported that this time it had taken on
the appearance of a beautiful seductive
woman during the initial proposals made
by the SCP 738 entity the inmate was
offered his free Freedom the price of
freedom is often high but the class D
may not have been expecting the price to
be the death of his best friend but the
inmate agreed to the terms of the deal
he'd been offered and vanished shortly
after 5 hours later though he was
recaptured by Foundation Personnel when
another member of Class D Personnel a
non-native English speaker sat down to
bargain with SCP 738 The Entity
communicated with him in his first
language their deal while similar to the
previous test used more specific wording
the class D inmate asked for the power
to never be held in a Cell Again rather
than just for Freedom the priced asked
for by the SCP 738 entity this time was
every memory of the man's Mother after
he accepted an incident broke out which
resulted in the inmate's death as well
as that of 12 Foundation guards the next
test the foundation conducted into the
effects of SCP 738 involved yet another
class D this time utilizing an inmate
with dyslexia and a mental disability
who reported that the entity appeared to
take the form of a large pink rabbit
once again adapting to the subject
before it the entity Drew crude
pictograms on its parchment trying to
convey a deal to the latest class D to
sit across the desk from it there were a
few words scattered about the page in
English but mostly unrelated insults
aimed at the inmate's intelligence or
questioning the man's understanding of
the deal The Entity was proposing the
entity offered the man a sloppy joe
stating the price to be mopsy the name
given to a toy that the inmate had
smuggled into the foundation and been
allowed to keep upon accepting the deal
A Fine China plate appeared in front of
the man with the promised sandwich upon
it the man quickly finished the food
that the entity had provided only to
become distressed when he realized that
mopsy had vanished shortly after the
test had concluded Foundation staff
issued the class D with another toy
identical to the one that had been
bargained away from him however as soon
as he named the new toy mopsy it too
disappeared once again causing the
inmate a great deal of emotional
distress further testing found that
there was little that could damage the
furniture of SCP 738 Foundation
researchers even tried exposing it to
explosives to no effect despite
appearing to be crafted from Mahogany
neither the desk nor the chairs were
able to catch fire and burn gunshots did
not tear through the woodwork as one
would expect
and even a mechanical wood chipper did
nothing to cause even the slightest of
damage there was however one thing that
did when directly attacking the desk
with an axe a single gash was left
scored into the mahogany Surface by the
bladed head this did unfortunately lead
to the death of the Personnel wielding
said Axe and afterwards the mark left in
the desk began gradually healing
changing their approach the foundation
ceased sending class D Personnel to make
deals with whatever Dev appeared sitting
at the desk instead a researcher took
the seat opposite and before the entity
began its usual stream of offers to
filled deep desires the researcher asked
a simple question what are you the SCP
738 entity took the form of a huge snake
and answered I'm sorry it's against
policy to divulge personal details but
may I interest you in it is unknown what
the entity offered the researcher but
the session was called to be halted
shortly after the foundation researcher
was institutionalized pending
psychiatric review the final test of SCP
738 involved a Mr Sheldon cats senior
Council of the foundation's legal
department who presented The Entity with
a fully legally water type document
stating he was not acting on behalf of
the SCP Foundation and was testing SCP
738 of his own free agency Mr Katz
reported that in this instance the SCP
738 entity assumed the form of a
professor who had touched Sheldon during
his first year of law school but didn't
include any information as to what sort
of deal The Entity had offered him after
41 hours of debate during which a 900
Page Long agreement between him and SCP
738 was drafted Mr Katz eventually
passed out from sheer overwhelming
exhaustion a red leather envelope was
found on him when he was removed from
the testing room containing a
handwritten note and smelling heavily of
sulfur the note simply read please
please come back anytime I haven't had
so much fun in years the incidents
involving SCP 738 all follow a
strikingly similar pattern after
adjusting to the person before it both
appearing in a form specific to them and
communicating with them in such a way
that they will best understand the SCP
738 entity will attempt to entice their
latest Emptor with their deepest desires
when the person opposite them makes a
request the entity brings up the
question of price while they can be
negotiated with it will insist that the
price be of equal value to what is being
requested like for like perhaps even a
soul for a soul it is worth noting that
the entity that sits in that Throne will
not always follow through on deals if
they determine the person making the
requests does not want the object enough
or if they request an object for someone
else as a way of trying to dodge paying
the full price it seems that this entity
being the bargainer that it is does not
not indulge requests that are made to
affect other people or for items that
can easily be passed onto others
accepting a deal with whatever devil
appears across that desk from you will
make your wish come true isn't that how
deals with the devil always go after all
you are certain to get whatever you ask
for anything your heart desires if
you're willing to pay the right price
for it just make sure that you always
read the fine print of that agreement
before you sign because the price won't
always be something you're willing to
pay you're sitting in the middle of a
cheering crowd the arena around you is
electric fans hollering from their seats
as they watch the basketball game every
Point scored every shot missed and every
skillful pass of the ball sends waves of
excitement over everyone in the audience
Applause shouts and chant fill the air
it distracts you for a moment you find
yourself swept up in the energy of the
game but slowly surely a nagging feeling
creeps up on you as your eyes follow the
ball that feeling turns to a sickening
realization as one of the players jumps
and dunks the basketball scoring another
two points you notice the look on his
face the same look on the faces of all
the other players on the court a solemn
hopeless expression it's the same look
of Silent despair worn by all the
spectators around you then you remember
you've watched this exact game of
basketball before many many times before
and that is when you feel the same
hopeless expression appear on your own
face realizing just how long you have
been here watching this game over and
over reminded that you will never ever
leave this Arena welcome to SCP
1733 to the untrained eye SCP 1733 seems
to be a completely harm less item stored
in a digital video recorder it is kept
securely in the dusty depths of the SCP
foundation's video archives if any
researcher is given permission to study
SCP 1733 they will find it to be an
ordinary VHS tape but what about the
contents of said tape does it contain a
bizarre disconnected series of black and
white video clips that when viewed only
give the Watchers 7 days before the
spirit of a drowned girl comes crawling
out of their TV screen to kill them well
not exactly but we're sure that if such
a tape exists the foundation probably
has it under lock and key too the
footage on SCP 1733 is as seemingly
benol as the ordinary VHS tape itself
when played the viewer will witness a TV
broadcast of a basketball game
specifically the 2010 2011 NBA season
opener broadcast on television and
captured on tape by an unknown civilian
the game took place on the 26th of
October 2010 in the TD Garden arena in
Boston Massachusetts a game where the
hometown Boston Celtics took on the
Miami Heat by now perhaps you wondering
what is so special about this particular
game and why the SCP Foundation would be
so interested in keeping a VHS recording
of it so secure is one of the 05 Council
secretly a Celtics fan well that's
impossible to say for sure what we do
know for certain is that SCP 1733 is far
more than just a harmless recording of a
basketball game the SCP Foundation First
caught wind of SCP 1733 existence the
day after the game on October 27th a
Boston native that had watched and
recorded the game made comments on
social media about a technical foul that
the game's referee had failed to pick up
on according to this individual during
the third quarter an instance of
unsportsmanlike conduct took place
between Ray Allen and Chris Bosch the
person making these claims was quickly
ridiculed by commenters on the same
thread but then this person uploaded a
clip of this foul from the footage they
had recorded the other commenters were
dumbfounded during the original
broadcast that foul had never happened
but the recording showed it clearer as
day the footage was quickly expunged and
all traces of the clip removed from the
Internet by Personnel acting on behalf
of the SCP Foundation any that had
viewed the video on Facebook or been a
part of the comments debating this
previously non-existent foul were
Tracked Down via their IP addresses all
of them including the owner of the tape
were given amnestics to wipe their
memories of the supposed infraction and
SCP 1733 was returned to the foundation
for further analysis researchers at the
foundation were determined to understand
the anomalous nature of SCP
1733 and why the footage contained on
this particular VHS tape was so
different from the basketball game's
original broadcast at first the
differences in the game seemed to be
only light changes from the one that
actually aired on TV a different foul
here a small Point difference there
while the recording of the game
contained on SCP 1733 was slightly
different from the real life game
perhaps even more interesting was that
these differences changed with repeat
viewings researchers wouldn't observe
the same differences every time they
watched SCP
1733 but would instead spot something
different that had been changed each
time they restarted the the tape and as
they continued to watch and rewatch SCP
1733 footage the true horror of the
video's anomalous properties became more
and more apparent as the footage
recorded on SCP 1733 began to diverge
more and more from the original
broadcast researchers shifted their
attention away from the basketball game
itself and on to the people watching it
just like the specifics of the game
itself the fans in the arena seemed to
also change with every rewatch of the T
and even stranger the people in the
crowd seemed to not only be aware of
their existence within the footage but
also retain memories of every previous
replayed Vision each time the
researchers had watched SCP 1733 the
audience trapped within had gained more
and more cognizance every man woman and
child in the audience of that basketball
game began remembering that they had
seen multiple variations of the same
game over and over again this first
became apparent to Foundation
researchers when the game's commentators
two presenters named Mike and Tommy
began to comment on a strange sense of
deja vu they were experiencing as they
watched the Boston Celtics and Miami
Heat play both seemed to share Notions
that the game they were witnessing was
strangely familiar and in later replays
of the tape these two commentator
personalities were able to recall the
events of the game with perfect Vivid
accuracy while they never addressed the
viewer directly this cumulative effect
seemed seems to have extended to every
person that was present within the arena
at the time that the original broadcast
was recorded everyone from the
commentators to the coaches the players
to the patrons all remember the
diverging versions of the basketball
game but seem to have no awareness that
they are trapped inside a recording on a
VHS tape it should be noted that it is
still unclear whether the entities are
real people or digital copies that
solely reside on the tape every
individual shown known to be inside TD
Garden on the 26th of October 2010 seems
to be identical to their counterparts in
the real world each of the basketball
players on both the Boston Celtics and
Miami Heat teams have the exact same
level of talent as they do in reality
and their individual mannerisms are
perfectly recreated in the SCP 1733
footage and the same is true of the fans
and the audience each one appearing to
be in every conceivable way a living
human being but the most unnerving
aspect of SCP 1733 was found when the
foundation agents were tasked with
tracking down members of the audience
who were seen on the tape and they found
nothing unlike the players and coaches
who can quite easily be found in our
world with many of them still playing or
involved with professional basketball
Personnel were unable to find a single
trace of any of the people from the
audience not one clue as to their
current whereabouts or status it is
unclear how but it appears appears that
everyone shown on SCP
1733 especially those watching the game
unfold from the stands is a person
trapped in digital form stuck watching
variations of the same match on Loop
researchers at the SCP Foundation who
were studying SCP 1733 initially
theorized that the tape had been
designed to display an infinite variety
of different game outcomes given that
the tactics utilized by the players were
different with each playback of SCP
1733 this seemed to be the case that the
tape was showing a whatif scenario each
time the tape was rewound and played
from the start but the scenario wasn't
resetting each time it was clear that
they were learning by the 34th replay of
the footage the Boston Celtics and Miami
Heat were so in tune with the opposing
team's Playbook that both sides players
were able to perfectly and precisely
counter their opponent's moves and kept
the score at 0 0 for much of the game
at this stage in the foundation's
research the players on the SCP 1733
tape had not yet become fully aware that
they had played the same game already in
earlier playbacks but it is possible
that weak memories of the earlier
versions of the same match manifested as
instinctive ways players could counter
the moves of their rival team however by
the time Foundation researchers had
replayed the SCP 1733 footage 45 times
the players their coaches and fans
watching the game had become aware of
what was happening to them it was at
this point that the digital recording
from TD Garden changed dramatically
realizing that they'd been playing the
same game of basketball over and over
the players refused to participate any
longer everyone in the audience began to
attempt to escape from the tape where
they'd been unknowingly imprisoned but
not a single one of the Stadium's doors
would budge and neither the fans nor the
players seemed to be able to leave
through any other exit out of TD garden
over the following playbacks of the SCP
1733 videotape attempts at Escape grew
increasingly daring in one playback a
full-scale riot broke out in another
makeshift explosives were built and used
by those trapped to try and blast their
way to Freedom as their cognition grew
and they began to remember friends and
family from outside the videotape the
crowd trapped in SCP 1733 grew even more
desperate players and their coaches
retired to locker rooms withdrawing from
the crowd for a Time the rest of the
people in the footage began to form
factions amongst themselves one of the
more prominent calling themselves the
faithkeepers these individuals voiced
their belief that they had been confined
to TD Garden as some form of spiritual
punishment as a result of the
consumerism that is Rife in a
post-industrial society the faithkeepers
began burning offerings in the center of
the basketball court phones wallets car
keys anything that reminded them of the
modern world over the subsequent quent
playbacks of SCP 1733 the faithkeepers
grew in their numbers indoctrinating
more of the crowd into their movement
those still trying to escape from the
stadium were causing more damage to
themselves than their enclosure with
three men caught in the blast of another
crude bomb placed on an exit door
unfortunately for them the door barely
showed a scratch in the aftermath of the
detonation as Foundation researchers
continued replaying the tape those
trapped with an SCP 17 33 descended into
depraved acts and incidences of violence
became rampant some even attempted to
take their own lives in Acts of
desperation jumping from balconies in
the hopes of ending the loop those that
had joined the growing ranks of the
faithkeepers did not engage in such
Behavior instead creating makeshift
curtains to separate themselves from the
breakdown that was taking place among
the others trapped within the SCP 1733
tank at some point beyond the the 112th
playback of the videotape the
faithkeepers marched off scream and
brought the basketball teams back out
onto the main Court they then began a
ritualistic sacrifice disbaling the
professional athletes for their fellow
prisoners to see this had no noticeable
effect with the recording of the game
resetting as it had done in earlier
rewatches in a later playback the
faithkeepers then began to call for all
the children in the stadium to be
sacrificed in the same way testing on
SCP 1733 was finally suspended
indefinitely after this point and as far
as we know the crowd remains trapped
inside the anomalous recording of this
particular Celtics Heat basketball game
Foundation researchers have been unable
to produce the same anomalous effects as
those of SCP
1733 even when using the DVR that
originally produced the recording the
digital video recorder itself does not
seem to imprint the same properties onto
other VHS tapes making SCP 1733 an
isolated anomaly however the next time
you find yourself at a basketball game
it might be worth asking yourself have I
seen this game before now check out SCP
1861 the crew of the HMS winter shimer
and SCP 1337 The Hitchhiker for more
Chilling Tales from the SCP Foundation